Oh.
The...
The main menu changed.
Wow.
Ahoy there, lady.
Welcome back to Trench.
Welcome back.
We're back.
And it's for some reason now says complete edition.
Curious.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome back to Trench.
I love fishing, as you can tell from my hat.
I put it like this and I feel like Spongebob.
I feel like...
How Spongebob has his hat.
Sick hat.
Thanks.
How am I feeling today?
I'm a little...
I'm a little okay.
I'm not so great, I'll be honest.
I just lied to you.
But it's okay.
I'm just fishing.
And I'm eating rice.
Rice.
But I'm excited to fish.
You're as addicted to this game as I am addicted to you.
You like fishing?
Oh my gosh, instead of...
Instead of Barry the Beat going, you like jazz?
He should have said, you like fishing?
I think everybody should like fishing.
What does the hat say?
Women fear me, fish fear me.
Men turn their eyes away from me as I walk.
No beast dare make a sound in my presence.
I am alone on this barren earth.
I have to be extra small today because my head is so big.
Why are you guys blushing?
What are you blushing about?
Fishing is cute.
Agreed.
Atonement for my sins.
What is this for?
What did you do?
What did you not do?
I feel like fishing mintos.
Aren't you on vacation?
Go away.
Gargle a lemon.
Thanks for the 10 gift.
Thank you.
I would happily.
I love lemon.
I'll eat a whole lemon.
I'll ask my friends for their lemon.
If they have a lemon, I'll just rip it out and be like...
I'm like that.
I will try sleeping with your stream in the background.
I don't think I'll scream today, so I think you'll be able to sleep.
Thank you for the 20 gift.
Love your minto manga script.
Oh, I think I saw that.
The...
The lewd one.
The one where it's like I am dying.
And Doki is like...
Sad.
Lemon stealing memes?
I love lemons.
I can't help it.
I don't steal.
I always ask.
I say, hey, are you going to eat your lemon?
Hey, are you going to eat that?
Hey, are you going to use that?
Are you going to use your lemon?
Well, even if they use it, I'll still eat it.
My girlfriend and I started reading Morning Glory.
And it's great.
Violet is a lucky girl.
Thanks for the recommendation.
Oh my gosh.
Couples activity.
Wait.
I think there was a new one that I was going to start last night and I fell asleep.
Hold on.
What's my... What's my... Oh, this is the app.
I have a new book that I might be starting.
The Orc Boss.
Oh, how am I 60% of the way through this book?
What?
60% of the book complete.
When?
Huh?
Let me read you the...
This is the synopsis.
Oh my God, it's long.
Okay.
Sky knows the only way to get over her ex is to get under someone new.
But what if that someone is an Orc Mafia...
An Orc Mafia boss.
Sky Brooks is an independent fae living in a modern world.
Though her culture's old-fashioned beliefs...
Wait.
Though her culture's old-fashioned beliefs insist she get married and have lots of babies.
A.S.A.P.
What is this fairy lore that I never knew about?
As much as Sky tries to follow tradition, she's just trying to have lots of babies, you guys.
She is unceremoniously dumped by her boyfriend after a decade together.
To add insult to injury, his booty calls keep coming in and Sky answers...
Oh, I do remember that.
That's the beginning of the book.
Oh my gosh.
I do.
Oh, I guess I did start this before.
Oh yeah, he booty calls her and she's just like, I'm back at my boyfriend's or my ex-boyfriend's house.
Sky answers every time.
To break this toxic cycle, she knows her only option to get over her ex is to get under someone new.
Ansel Walsh is an orc mobster on a mission.
Avenge his parents' death.
Gosh, there's a lot going on here.
He spends every waking moment dismantling his uncle's criminal business.
I don't think he has time for babies, though.
Thank you for the gifted.
Walsh.
No, his name is Ansel.
A-N-S-E-L.
Ansel the orc.
Please start a book club, I beg.
No!
One night, while hunting his uncle's cronies, he inadvertently takes the place of Sky's back alley hookup.
Whoa!
That's not a boy whose parents would be so disappointed.
One handsy interaction later... I must have fallen asleep before all of this happened.
Ansel's secret...
One handsy interaction later, she becomes his unwilling captive.
Whoa!
I thought she was trying to get a boyfriend.
Ansel... I can't get over this name.
Swears he's only kidnapping Sky to keep her safe.
It's a protective kidnapping.
Please understand.
But when she wakes to find herself handcuffed to his bed, she feels a lot of things.
Safe isn't one of them.
I'm in tears.
I'll let you know how this one goes, guys.
I'll start it tonight and I'll actually pay attention.
Yeah, we need updates?
Okay.
I got you.
Anyway, shall we dredge?
When does the minotaur show up?
I don't know.
Who's in this?
Happy fishing.
Thank you!
Book report.
I do that, like, every couple of streams.
That Among Us collab looks super stacked.
Hope you have lots of fun.
Thank you!
I'm nervous about all my collabs this week.
Shall we dredge?
Am I meant to go block today?
Somehow my plushie, even though I ordered from the second batch...
Oh!
I hope I didn't get someone else's order.
Maybe I got lucky.
Congrats?
Thank you.
So last time, we have new quests.
We gotta go to the Twisted Strand.
This must be DLC.
I was not there.
Oh!
What the heck is this?
It's your two boyanos.
Welcome to Bamboo Ship.
Giant red circle.
There's no other ones.
Let's go to the big red circle.
What time is it?
Oh, it's kind of late.
I think I sold everything.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll repair since we're here.
Oops, wrong thing.
A lot of people are getting their Mint merch, it seems today, because I've seen a lot of posts about it.
Everybody is posting really funny things.
Thank you everybody for all the orders.
Thank you.
Research farming?
There's no farming.
What are you talking about?
Sorry, I'm still eating my rice.
I'm almost done.
Daimu!
I love this game.
I'm so obsessed.
Freaky way to start my morning.
Michael Smeltos?
What the heck is that?
I can't really do anything.
I guess we'll just fish until nighttime and then we'll make the big journey to...
Um...
To...
What's it called?
It's that direction, I believe.
What fish have we not gotten in this area?
Let's see.
Encyclopedia.
Where are the ste... No, Gale Cliffs.
Ooh, fancy.
This?
Oceanic?
Only at night.
Shallow, the sky.
What?
Minto chat is so nice.
I love you, Daimu!
Oh yeah, there's 230 fish now.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, are these new fish?
Wait, why are they golden?
Uh-oh.
Maybe I bought things and, um...
I bought the DLC and now everything is like, expanded like crazy.
Everything's in the 5 gift set.
I
might start doing the wrench thing again.
What's that sound?
Daimu, would you be the honors of my first wrench since I've been back?
I think it'd be like, maybe it'd be easier to see people.
I use the YTC chat too.
I just...
Um...
Add.
I didn't... I didn't want to make anyone feel pressure with it, but...
Yes, I will do that.
What does that mean?
Don't worry about it.
No pressure.
Do you think that guy is going to come out?
And eat me?
Wait!
This is the thing that I was like...
Oh, I don't have this guy.
We literally found him just now.
What is this?
A wreck fish.
Who hurt you?
Uh-oh.
It's nighttime.
I can't see anything.
I got a devil ray.
Giving moderation powers to someone who has no clue how YouTube...
No!
It's like...
It's like the special...
What's this?
Oh yeah, the stone.
It doesn't respond to my touch.
I don't have the special touch.
It's like a VIP on Twitch.
Right guys?
Ouch!
Don't worry.
We are OK.
You gelatinous...
I lost my fish!
I lost my wreck fish.
At least we got him, right?
So that I could...
What's that sound?
Uh-oh.
Guys, I think something is coming after me.
What's that noise?
What's coming after me?
I'm curious.
Let's fix our boat.
OK.
Alright.
It's fine.
So...
I do want to point out...
I did buy the DLC.
Wait, what happened?
We back?
What happened?
YouTube is very strange.
It's not my end because...
My thing is fine.
What I was saying...
I don't know how much of it I'll do.
For the DLC.
Just kind of know that like...
People said it has cool upgrades and things like that.
So...
Oops, sorry.
We're going this way.
Trying to figure out how memberships work and thought I broke something.
You might have, that's OK.
OK.
We're on the right track.
Limus, stop it.
Why are you joining membership?
Stop!
Yo-ho, yo-ho.
We're going out to sea.
Let's go see what it is.
I found a white and mint colored...
Golf ball yesterday.
And lost it three strokes and...
Unlucky.
Dang, this thing is far.
Are we almost there?
Is that it?
The island?
I don't know what we're heading out to.
We're almost there.
That's...
An island.
I thought that was another boat for a second.
Wait, what?
Honestly, I have no idea what the DLC is.
I just got it.
It's icy.
We're in Antarctica.
It's getting night.
It's getting dark.
What's this right here?
Is this a dock?
Or that's a...
That's that.
What is this?
A shipwreck?
This is a man!
Oh, it's the hooded man!
Thank you for your dredge streams.
These have been really fun and cozy.
I got it.
So I can play along and he's gonna lurk and work with it.
Good fishing.
Thanks Fallen!
Thank you so much for the super chat.
The ice.
We hear their jaws snap shut again from the cold.
The ice takes form.
A type ice?
Oh my gosh.
He's an aberrated...
This guy is asking for a lot.
Can I squeeze through there?
I don't think I should.
I think I should find...
Shelter?
Or something.
I think I'm gonna die out here, honestly.
I might die out here.
Hello?
Anyone alive out here?
It's kinda spooky.
No.
Wait.
I thought I saw light.
Is that light?
What is that?
Land?
No!
It is.
It is light.
What's happening?
Something spooky is here.
I'm getting... I'm getting cursed.
What's happening?
I'm scared.
I see eyeballs.
Nah, it was nothing.
Must have been the wind.
Wind.
Excuse me.
Leave me alone.
Check the map.
I'm like... I'm barely inside.
I've just been going along the edge.
That looks like...
Oh, I see the lighthouse even from here.
That is probably a spooky guy, no?
He's gonna come alive and...
Try and grab me?
Probably.
I'm in the mist!
Is this thing still chasing after me?
It is.
I hear it still.
I hear it coming after me.
What is that?
How do I get in there?
Oh my goodness.
The sun is rising.
Thank you.
Just a normal, normal water spout.
Hello.
So evil.
Thank you.
Is this also evil?
Or...
Oh, the stone trembles before you.
Unknown symbols glow from within.
A sudden...
This stone I can touch!
A sudden chill rushes through the marrow of your bones, surging up your arm, your neck.
A deep vision enters your mind.
Intruders.
They invade on tiny wooden vessels, shouting and smelling.
They cut and slice with angled metal, breaking across a skin of ice.
Their meager hearts beat with... rice.
And pride!
Desires trivially twisted into new shapes.
Shapes that might mend and restore.
Shapes to replace what was lost down in the dark.
Hole?
What does that mean?
How do I get inside?
I love rice.
I'm eating rice right now.
What the?
Did you guys see that?
That don't look good.
Me next?
Okay, maybe I can get in.
I have to be very...
Something's crackling.
I have to be really careful.
Do I need C4, maybe?
It's crackling.
That was awesome, yeah.
Hello?
I'm not gonna take this right now, because...
A lot of crackling noise.
Because I don't know what will happen to us, you know?
Crunchy.
Go away, water spout.
Is he home?
Maybe that one way was my way through.
Can I fish here?
Oh, I see.
I do need ice.
Ice breaking ASMR.
Sounds nice.
I'm still a little freaked out.
You can kinda see my sanity took a bit of a hit.
Unlucky my soul.
Thank you so much for the 5 gifted.
Thank you!
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
This is probably like...
You need to break it up.
No?
How do I get through?
You want to offer your what?
Oh, super chat.
This is my first time.
I hope you can be gentle with me.
Today is my birthday.
Can I ask for a happy birthday, please?
Of course!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Sotomi!
Happy birthday!
Thank you.
If I crash into this...
Oops.
Okay.
It was for science.
How do I get in?
There's no prompt for like...
There's also like a glowing light back there.
It's very faint.
I don't know if you guys can see it.
Wait!
There's sea machinery over here!
Where were you before?
I guess we can go in from here.
Maybe?
No?
Everything is blocked off.
No, it's not the lighthouse.
I saw a much thinner line.
Down here to investigate the ice field too?
It seems to have appeared out of nowhere.
My best guess is that it drifted from up the south.
Either way, I thought I should set up a pontoon here.
But when I went to stake my claim, I noticed some old equipment on the ice.
Come and check it out when you got a second.
In the meantime, I've got some new rods for sale.
They'll be perfect for fishing in the ice around here.
Icy workshop, yeah.
Oh, it's so weird.
This stuff seems old.
Like really old.
She kicks a large sheet of metal, half embedded in the ice.
A thin layer of snow dislodges, revealing lines of rivet holes.
Come in here, look!
We follow her into a small makeshift shelter.
Ruined by years of harsh weather.
Inside are some schematics nailed to a table, still barely legible.
This reminds me of when I was in Antarctica.
I got to go into a research base that was from like the early 1900s.
And in the bathrooms...
In the bathroom?
Bathrooms.
In the one bathroom, in the bathroom, they had like pin-up girls on the walls.
And I was like...
I guess we're, you know, we're lonely in the Antarctic.
And they were sexy.
But yeah, everything is still really well preserved in it because it's so cold, right?
And...
You got to visit Antarctica?
Yeah, I did.
I got to go to Antarctica and...
I got to have a really fun time.
I might be the first Vtuber to go to Antarctica.
Fun.
You follow her into a small makeshift shelter.
Oh, inside there are some schematics.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
See how they angled these sheets and the lining of the metal around the bowl?
Whoever was here, I think they were constructing an icebreaker.
Would you make another one using these plans?
Probably.
But let me see.
She trudges outside again and paces out the length of the metal scraps on the ice.
We've got most of the basic materials here already, but of course we're missing the most crucial pieces.
Antarctica stream win?
Actually, I wanted to.
If I ever go back, I'll be the first Vtuber to stream in Antarctica.
It was expensive though, so I probably won't be back.
It was kind of a once-in-an-after-lifetime experience, maybe.
An icebreaker needs specially tempered angled metal, as well as components designed to minimize the impact to your hull.
I can't see any of those here, but whoever left all this stuff, maybe they left other pieces elsewhere.
Or maybe you'll be able to find their old ship and salvage the icebreaker they already built.
That would be convenient.
Anyway, let's build a new icebreaker.
What are these?
These are the parts we'll need.
Ma'am, I've never seen that ever.
What's the new one?
Oh, the Pale Reach.
Oh, and the Iron Rig.
Oh, these are the things I bought.
I was like, Dredge DLC pays money.
Did I read it?
No.
Wow.
Anyway, I ran into some ice, thinking that I could break it, you know?
You should really be more careful.
Sorry.
Sorry, ma'am.
Barbed ice rod...
Interesting,
interesting.
So we didn't have to research that.
That's kind of nice.
Breeding is for nerds.
Oh, we have an ice troll net too.
Giant.
Giant light.
I don't think I can do the explosives.
I wonder if there's anything new, new research stuff that we can get.
That's all the same.
This is all the same.
These are all the same.
Same.
Gonna need a bigger boat.
This is all the same.
Such a... shanty.
To honor such day.
Oh, it's your birthday.
Happy time.
Happy... day on the sea.
Oh, the sea.
Superliminal, it's your birthday.
Alright.
Happy birthday.
Not your best work Meantime.
What are you talking about?
I think it was probably the greatest.
Did I, did I repair?
No, I did not.
Oh, it's expensive this time.
Well, at least we sell our fish and it costs... We got our money back.
Geneva, thanks for 11 months.
Thank you.
Oh, let's rest.
Beautiful.
Thank you, Pinto.
Of course!
That was a good song.
The music is crazy right now.
I don't think, I don't know if I can go in here.
Let's try it though.
Of course we can try.
Oh, it's kind of spooky.
It's kind of scary.
I don't think I can fish here.
Rocks everywhere.
Oh, tiny boat.
What are you doing in there?
Tiny boat.
The photographer?
Fisherman, I didn't expect to see you this far south.
Well, this is a fortunate turn of events.
There's a narwhal somewhere in this ice field.
I couldn't get any further in, so I've been trying to take a picture from here with no luck.
I tried placing some scraps of fish on that ice sheet over there to entice it, but I didn't have enough to hold its attention for long enough.
I only caught a glimpse.
Don't suppose you have any fish you'd prepare to donate to the pursuit of wildlife photography?
Okay, fill the space entirely with any fish you'd like.
I can't imagine the narwhal is too picky.
Alright.
Narwhal.
Interesting.
Oh, we definitely gotta get some ice stuff.
The
boat goes bento.
Welcome back, all men.
Thank you.
Oh, see, see?
That light.
Oh wait, that's probably... this.
The iron rig.
Let's go check it out.
Let's get out of the ocean.
Not the ocean, the ice.
Oh, Christmas.
Sounds like Christmas music.
How are there palm trees?
Where are we anyway?
Okay, so we definitely gotta get to the twisted strand.
I guess we'll head that way, huh?
On our way to the light.
What is this?
Is this wood?
What?
What is this?
Iron Haven crate?
DLC box.
Whoa!
Time to go check it out.
Check it out, check it out.
Check it out, very useful DLC box.
Good to know, good to know.
Today?
One moment please.
It's gonna be dark after I fish this, but that's okay.
This is the ghost.
The ghost shark is good money, no?
Ghost.
Oh, more?
I guess I sell... you could say I sell... I'm worthless.
Or priceless.
No, worth a lot of money.
Wait, what's the saying?
I got my myth plush in Magnus today.
Have you seen the anime film Belle?
If not, may I suggest a membose?
I haven't seen it.
Spooky mist.
Spooky boat.
There's so many lights now, everywhere.
Don't go to the boat.
He doesn't see me, right?
You don't see me, right mister?
What are those?
What's these lights?
These fish?
Spooky boat.
How do I get inside?
I can't tell which direction I'm coming in from.
Oh, I can tell which direction I'm coming in from.
Hello home.
Wow, it's so weird seeing this in the distance, right?
The boat you noticed yesterday?
The DLC reused them for box locations.
Hello.
I like to sell.
Alright, nice.
Um...
Maybe I should've probably bought some stuff.
Should've bought some research things maybe.
That's okay.
I wasn't quite ready to get the ice stuff or do any of the ice stuff just yet.
If I do the light upgrade...
This one, plus one light space.
Even that, how are we supposed to get that big ol' big guy?
Read the box?
Can I open it?
It's full of materials.
Sleep, and then we'll go to the iron...
The new place.
And then...
The
world's flimsiest boat.
I have the world's flimsiest boat.
I even sighed.
I even did a sigh of relief.
I was like...
Just barely missed it.
This game...
Oh, we're going to Mother Base!
Built with flex tape.
I've never been in an accident phantom, y'all.
I have it!
With my car!
I'm not boat licensed.
You can't trust me on the seas.
Oh, we finished our book!
Advanced Fishing.
What did I get?
Make a pile of fish.
Oh, I was like, what the hell are you talking about?
Advanced Fishing.
Fishing rods will reel 15% more effectively.
Yippee!
She really is Spongebob.
Maybe.
MSF!
It's Mother Base, everybody!
What's here?
What could be here that we have DLC for?
Can I dock here?
This looks like a dock.
You dock in a small metal wharf.
Four giant legs stretch down into the deep, lifting a mountain of metal into the sky.
Oh my gosh, you know what's so fascinating and terrifying is like watching...
I've watched like some...
I say documentaries, but it's like documentary style, you know?
It's not like a full documentary.
But just about the people that like build these types of things.
It's scary.
That book seems less than interesting.
Where is the vengeful lord?
So true.
Those types of jobs are so scary.
Is it that dangerous?
Yes!
Oh my gosh, it's really dangerous.
Super bear hero, welcome to membership!
Thank you!
You dock...
Cargo elevator.
Oh, we're going in.
An elevator connecting the docking area to the main platform lies ahead.
A man waits nearby, a yellow hard hat strapped to a concerned expression.
What do you want?
Who are you?
I'm the site foreman, and this is the Iron Haven Corporation's new drilling rig.
Or it would be.
If we were on schedule, right now it's just a platform.
It's Wario.
The boss is gonna dock our pay for sure if he shows up and the drill hasn't even started.
We've got the foundational stuff laid, but we've been running into some supply issues.
He glances nervously at the water, large waves rolling underneath the shadow of the platform.
The ships delivering crates of materials keep going missing.
An HQ said they're not able to dispatch anymore for a few weeks.
Look, I wouldn't normally ask a civilian for help, but we're already so far behind.
Why don't I mark the last known coordinates of those ships on your map?
Oh, I've gotten them.
If you're able to find any of those crates, I'm sure the corp...
I found both of them.
Wait, do you have a...
There you go.
Easiest mission ever.
That ought to be enough to get the generator going.
I'll get these materials sent up to the main platform.
Wow, they're efficient.
So that should be in working order, but I just checked the storeroom and it looks like we've never got any fuel deliveries.
I did find this though.
You can use it to patch things up in a pinch.
Oh, keep it.
It's the least I can do in return for your help.
While I go and figure out the fuel situation, why don't you introduce yourself to the head scientist?
Oh my gosh, we've got Revolver Ocelot and we're gonna go talk to Otacon.
He's always interested to hear about the local fish species.
Science lab.
Otacon's looking rough.
Huey?
Don't mention his name.
More like Huey.
That guy's no scientist.
That guy's a fraud.
He literally said he stole the... Anyway.
You approach an old man pacing back and forth.
Definitely couldn't be Huey then.
Near a poor known off area on the main platform.
He's muttering to himself quietly.
Who are you?
Ah, the angler turned courier.
Isn't that right?
The workers were talking about you.
All good things, I promise.
Say, you must know a great deal about the fish species around here, yes?
Have you encountered in these waters?
You wouldn't believe me if I told you.
Instead of rolling his eyes as most people do when they sense a fisherman's tail approaching, the scientist's eyes glisten with an intense curiosity.
Is that so?
Perhaps he'll find me a little more imaginative than others.
Before we get into all that though, it seems my laboratory is also a victim of a missing supply shipment.
I was planning on conducting research into fish species in the area, but I can't do that without somewhere to study.
Do we have that on the map?
Oh, look at that.
They're all like... It's very close.
Wait, which way am I facing?
Is it this way?
This way?
Right here?
Yeah.
Where's signs?
I didn't even need to put a marker.
It was literally two feet away.
Okay.
Wow.
Yikes.
Wait, is this another one?
Oh my goodness.
Strand-type island is here too.
Yeah, I know.
We're right next to it.
So I was gonna go deliver this and then...
Oh, there's more?
I'm scared of what creatures are around here.
Not gonna lie.
Mist be gone.
It worked.
No, it didn't work.
Nevermind, the mist is literally on the ship.
I'm docking.
Leave me alone.
Okay, bye.
No, you're mist fish.
It's different.
The detail with the sunken ship is awesome.
You would think that they would notice.
You know?
They would be like...
There's that guy over there.
Oh, we've got enough material for the science lab now too.
We'll get to work.
We're really constructing another base.
That should be enough space for your tubes and fluids, eh?
Why do you guys say it like that?
Curious.
Phrasing, for sure.
I got some tea.
Let's look at the generator and I'll give you the rundown.
So it turns out the fuel never got dispatched from Iron Haven at all.
I was on the radio to HQ.
Apparently this is a biofuel generator.
It's some new tech the corp wanted to trial out here.
And they expected us to supply it ourselves.
Thing is, they didn't think to outfit us with any gear for harvesting biomass.
And the fleet services construction is way down on the project list.
We have science tea.
You think you can help us out again?
You can add fish or other biological material, I suppose, to the hopper here.
Once it's filled we ought to be able to start the drill.
Oh, look at that.
This might be perfect actually.
Do you think I have enough lobster?
Prawn?
Not enough prawn.
Dang, so close.
So close.
Let's just sleep.
What's the science lab doing?
How can I help you?
Oh, how long have you worked for the Iron Haven corporation?
Oh, Panko!
Thank you so much for the raid!
Hello, hello everybody.
Raymac, thanks for the 5 gifted.
We're playing Dredge.
I recently got the DLC and by recently I mean today.
But I'm obsessed with this game.
Panko, if you haven't played this game before, it's so fun.
It's so chill.
Paperbugs!
Thank you so much for the 5 gifted.
Thank you!
Furby, thank you for the 5 gifted.
Hello, hello everybody.
Welcome.
Shishi, thanks for the 5 gifted.
RugbyRubber, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Yeah, we're fishing.
We're fishing today.
Bearly, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Just came here and got gifted already.
Lucky, ducky.
Never heard of it?
It's so fun.
We're just...we're fishing.
And some fish are kinda creepy.
Actually, no.
Every fish is beautiful in its own way.
RustyNail, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Tizz himself, thanks for the 5 gifted.
There like might be a cult.
Maybe.
There might be like some otherworldly things happening.
It's NBT, no big deal.
Duargo, thank you for the 5 gifted.
My whole professional career has been dedicated to scientific research at the corporation.
So that's, well, north of half a century now.
Our current executive's father hired me when I was fresh out of college.
He must have seen something in me all those years ago.
Again.
We gotta get some fish.
But also, I wanna see if there's anything else underneath here.
We got some dolphins.
Oh, it's a little dolphin family.
How cute.
Let's check out.
Maybe this boat has some good items.
Oh, oh no!
It's not a boat!
I'm gonna run into the tree!
I didn't run into the tree.
Why are all the boats not boats anymore?
Denden!
Welcome to Babusha, thank you.
Why is nothing a boat anymore?
Research pot.
Lucky!
Like, this is probably not a...
This is probably not a plane either, huh?
What is this?
Dog tags.
A pair of dog tags.
A name, number, and address is printed in duplicate.
I can hear it though.
It's like creaking and cracking.
Maybe this thing is real.
Maybe this thing is legit.
What?
It's a quest.
It seems like it because it was like glowing.
It says the name Raiden.
Yeah guys, this is the game.
You just fish and it's a good time.
Okay, I'm gonna go towards it.
Really?
Nothing?
Okay.
We might have gotten enough fish now.
Nope, nevermind.
We need to find a few more.
The wind is leading me towards something spooky.
Not even a crab.
Nothing at all.
How disappointing.
There's some fish.
Amelia Earhart.
She got eaten by the crabs.
What is your theory for Amelia Earhart?
Didn't they find her like somewhat recently?
Aliens.
Alright.
That's definitely enough.
She was sent to another world.
If only we could all be so lucky.
Leave me alone!
She got isekai'd.
The original isekai-er?
Isekai-e.
Where's Amelia Earhart and fate go?
I got you some fish mister.
There you go.
Won't hold anymore.
I'll fire it up.
The crushing compactor clunks to life.
The sound of pneumatic pistons and strange squelching soon gives way to the stuttering sound of distant gears.
Not yet.
One day perhaps.
Wish she's a cute boy and fate go?
Amelia Earhart?
Why'd they make her a boy?
The Voyager satellite is in FGO.
Oh wow.
We've done it!
A large capsule drops down from the chute labeled Waste.
Though it's clear walls you can see remnants of the fish you deposited.
Well you probably will be able to use that for chum.
Canister of malignant fish remains adorned with warning stickers and caution labels.
Attracts wretched fish.
We can get some freaky fish with this.
Oh bait!
Now we can finally get this drill started.
All clear!
I was wondering if after you get done with the MGS series would you be interested in trying Max Payne?
Think you'd like it.
Also everyone knows Amelia Earhart got eaten by the coconut crabs.
Yeah that's why I said the crabs earlier.
What a way to go.
Initiating drill deployment in 3, 2, 1.
The drill descends.
Cut sand.
Are we going to get some freaky fish from this?
Oh that doesn't seem very good.
Wait this seems pretty bad actually.
Wait where is that headed to?
What is that?
What's that over there?
The scientist walks over gripping handrails to counteract the shockwaves from the drill.
We've broken through!
We're underway at last.
What about that huge crack that opened up?
Is the reservoir stable?
Admittedly the fissure is larger than my model suggested, but appears to have stabilized.
We should consider halting the drilling for now.
Planet Mike!
Thank you so much for the 50 gifts!
Thank you!
What the heck?
Thank you so much!
No we're not the bad guys.
We're just... I'm just a fisherman.
We would be remiss in our duties to the local population if we didn't survey the area and gather some data.
In that vein, fisherman, I have some...
I don't work here!
I have something for you.
The factory has recently become operational, allowing us to manufacture equipment infused with the corporation's latest breakthroughs.
This is the new design.
Oh wait.
Coastal up.
Shallow up.
I don't have room for this.
Oh, hold on.
I can store stuff.
Oh wait, I don't want to store this fish.
When do we get the pacific rim style giant mech of the... Oh my god!
I wish.
I guess I could have put that in storage too, huh?
Wes!
Thank you for the box!
Using that rod, I need you to collect specimen samples from the morrows.
Just check that the fish species are unaffected by our operations here.
Wow, there's so much here!
Wait, where did that fisher go to?
Hey fisherman, thanks again for your help filling out that generator.
I've reported our new operational status to HQ.
In fact, they've given me a budget to compensate you for any additional biomass you bring in.
Just see me at the generator and I'll pay you.
We get paid for our fish now.
I can now pay you for any biomass you add to the generator.
The bigger the better, I assume.
This isn't really my area.
Dead space.
Check your map and you can see the fisher zones.
Oh, thank you.
A figure emerges from lower decks and beckons you over into the shadows.
Gosh, there's so much here!
If you're going to be hanging around, maybe we could do business.
Come see me at the wonder market.
Hello.
Wait, everybody wants me!
Yeah, I'm just one fisherman, please!
Oh, he wants the samples.
Okay.
Got some items you might be interested in.
Don't ask where they came from.
Better off not knowing.
Can you make some basic repairs too?
Oh, can make some basic repairs too.
But it'll cost you.
Oh, he also sells ice things.
Okay.
Interesting.
You don't sell anything that's special.
I'll take some research parts though.
Okay, research.
We're researching this bad boy.
Yeah, the versatile rod.
It's just their shipyard, yeah, pretty much.
Nice.
Now we can get the harvesting platform.
Coastal shallow oceanic.
150% fishing speed!
It's nice to have as many... what's a foundry?
A helmeted figure emerges from the shadows by a building site.
He lifts his visor.
Places are broken.
He gestures to a pile of materials behind him.
Oh, I have it, I have it, I have it.
Thank you.
That's all we need.
We can get the foundry built.
Okay, easy.
Good to go.
Basic materials can be worked here.
Select a blueprint.
Oh, we can make more.
Or I can just go find them.
Like I've been doing.
We got the tech lab even.
When the tech lab is operational, we'll be able to work on projects of a more technical nature.
I have plans for the interchangeable module system.
You'll see.
I'll show you when we're set up here.
Clear out my storage.
Construct.
Everything appears to be in order.
MSF!
At last, I'm excited for you to try some of these out.
Enhanced lights.
Enhanced spyglass.
Enhanced fog horn.
Makes your presence known.
Forces to illuminate your surroundings.
Okay, interesting.
So they cost research parts and a...
And a crate.
Interesting.
This is so different.
All of a sudden, things are different.
But I am... Oh wait.
Maybe the foundry is still around, huh?
Oh yeah, this makes this.
Okay.
I can't find cloth still.
I've been looking for cloth.
Maybe the factory...
Welcome to the factory.
Oh my gosh, this is...
This changes everything.
What's like the setup?
I wish they had the...
You know, the floating... Oops, my bad.
The floating dock.
I wish they had that so that I could...
Research.
Or, not research.
Do the thing where I put the materials in, you know?
That's the key.
There isn't one.
Wow.
Alright, for now though...
Let's check our map.
I cannot get rid of this.
I didn't really need it there to begin with.
I wish I could get rid of the mark though.
I've already been there.
Oh, you can see it here.
I see, I see.
It looks so cool.
Cool!
Wait, what is it?
What's yelling at me?
It was like, there was an exclamation point, but I don't know what for.
I'm just following the line.
It's taking us to this one first.
Whoa!
It's so goopy.
Got the bait ability.
Oh, that's right!
Yes, thank you, thank you.
You guys know everything.
You're so smart.
Can I, like, go in this?
Or am I gonna die?
Only one way to find out.
I don't have the shallow...
Oh, I need shallow upgrade.
If I go through this, is it slow?
Slow.
Interesting.
That's so gross.
Hold on, though.
I do want to...
I don't... Oh, wait.
This place is always where it'll, like, respawn after a while.
So we finally got some more cloth.
Thank goodness.
Oh, seriously?
A stingy?
Is this a Strand-type game?
Unironically, yes.
Unironically, yeah, I think so.
One whole cloth.
Hey, beggars can't be choosers.
I'll take what I can get.
My single cloth.
Okay, but we definitely gotta get to...
The Strand.
We'll do that after.
I'm opening up so many more...
What's it called?
So many more...
Quests, and it's making me a little nervous.
Because I have so much to do, you know?
It's making my brain spin a little bit.
And I think I should...
I need two cloths!
Please!
So stingy!
We can do the engine space, I suppose.
I have so much material.
Of everything else.
Alright, we got engine space.
We can do the light space.
I don't need this, though.
Ah, whatever.
We gotta get it all eventually, you know?
I guess this place could use some...
Seamstresses!
You got a light chuckle out of me.
We could do the rod spaces, though.
We only need one cloth for that.
I'm debating.
Save for extra cargo.
I know, I want two also.
And then we're also gonna have to get...
I don't even know.
Four!
Four cloths!
That's insane!
That's craziness!
Insane!
Game, I need more, please!
Okay, so this is Coastal Shallow Bangor Volcanic.
Coastal Shallow.
This would be great.
But then I can't do Oceanic.
Like, I would have to...
I probably have to get rid of the trawl net, huh?
Can you buy cloth anywhere?
I don't think so.
I've never... I haven't seen it.
Oh, you can at the foundry.
If you get Tier 2 Foundry with Iron Rig, you can turn crates into cloth, wood, or salvage.
I see, I see, I see.
Oh yeah, I should sell my fish first, huh?
Good reminder.
Can
I get the mangrove and the volcanic?
Because we're about to kind of go into a mangrove area.
So, I guess we could just store these.
I'm assuming that the Abyssal and Hadol won't be in that area.
You can always swap rods.
Of course, obviously.
But only if I'm at an area I can, you know what I mean?
If I'm at an area that I can't, then I'm gonna...
Get a bit of a pickle.
Hadol is, I think, how you say it.
Oh, that's right, we got the infused rod too.
Let's...
Nah, we'll do this, because we're gonna go over there.
Uninstall.
And then install.
Oh wait, it's okay.
Uninstall please, sorry I messed up.
Install, thank you.
I feel like it would be better to have the space there.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Repair.
Sleep.
I miss Minto karaoke.
Well, you'll have some next week.
Some next week.
And let's go to the Twisted Strand.
Did I ever get that?
Did I ever get the...
No, I didn't do the upgraded engine, did I?
Ah, whatever.
Goopy.
I got some ooze!
Can I keep it?
It's kinda cute actually.
Really?
What if it oozed some fish onto me?
Hot dog!
What does it taste like?
What if it tastes like jelly?
Oh, I'm going the wrong way.
I need to be going north.
Hot dog.
Hot dog!
Minto just inked...
What am I, an octopus?
Octopus.
Okay!
Okay, okay.
Tastes like smoky BBQ.
I see you're not really...
You're just making it more and more enticing.
My hair kinda looks like a squid.
Well, I mean, I guess I do leave a little bit of like...
I mean, sometimes I leave like an ectoplasm.
If it's like, you know...
I can't help it.
It just happens sometimes.
Ooh, it's dusty here.
The snail trail?
Don't call it that!
What we got in our net?
Our net is huge.
I don't know if I like this place.
Is this the traveling merchant?
But that's like a ghosty thing, you know?
Like all ghosts do that.
Rickety pontoon.
I'm gonna store our cloth.
I'm gonna store our backs...
What is it called?
Oh, dark splash.
I thought it said backsplash.
Mintomucin.
Might be good for skin care.
I don't know.
I don't know, I don't know.
We're gonna rest too.
I know it's kind of early, but...
I don't wanna go in there and sun down.
You'd use it on your skin.
You would.
Here we go.
What is this?
Oh, that doesn't seem good.
What are you?
What is this?
Oh, it's really creaky.
Rickety.
Mushrooms.
Wait, what is this?
Hold on.
I should do some fishing in here.
Magrove.
I got a gar!
Trophy gar.
No!
It didn't even give me the opportunity.
Ok, let's just get a couple.
I got a message in a bottle.
Question mark, question mark, question mark.
There's something over here too.
Wait, what's this?
What are you?
Hello?
No!
I lost my gar!
What is this?
I was just trying to get close so I could...
Where are gar goes?
There's some scrap.
We'll come back.
What else is in here?
Ok, something else.
What are you?
A sergeant fish?
What's that?
I heard something make a not so pleasant sound.
You hear that?
What are you?
I thought that thing... I saw... There was something that poked its head out of the water earlier.
I thought it was like guarding the little thing.
So I was like, oh, ok.
It must be something that I drive up to.
Magrove.
I guess we got a...
I guess we got a repair again.
Your boat sprung a leak!
Oh, is that bad?
Oopsie.
I didn't realize it was that bad.
We were just casually dying, casually sinking.
No big deal.
Yeah, don't worry about it.
This area reminds me of Outer Wilds.
Maybe that's why I don't like it.
I've been thinking so much about Outer Wilds lately.
Just how much I miss it.
I'm really into this game, if you couldn't tell.
I do really like it.
I'm waiting for this guy to leave.
I think it's because I've been playing a lot of stressful-ish games lately.
And so, you know, some high action games and this one is very low key and I just feel good about it.
You know what I mean?
What's this?
Hello?
Why are there so many plane crashes here?
Woah!
They affect the mind?
I'm past saving.
Good thing we know that now.
They can't harm me.
What happened to them?
Nice hat.
Thanks.
I do?
You'll be up for it.
You'll have a look.
I do?
Guys, do I look rugged and hardened like I've been trained by the... by the... by the sea?
By the elements?
Yeah.
I'm hardened and rugged.
I've been trained by the sea!
I am... I looked into the void and I... I did this.
Shiny and pristine.
Oh.
We went down to the north and east of where we are now.
I can't do this anymore.
I'll mark the possible crash sites on your map.
You go and see what you can salvage.
I've got one.
I found parts of the mortar.
You found one component but it's still missing a piece.
Nearly there.
Keep looking.
How will you honor your squadmates?
I've hung a few of their dog tags.
Oh, the dog tags on the tree behind me is... Wait, that guy was pretty far out, no?
The void was not prepared.
Seems fitting enough, but I've only got tags from the ones I...
You must understand, I've never found all their bodies.
If you happen to find any of their dog tags, I could add them to the tree with their brothers.
I have a number of mechanical doodads that might be useful.
Here, take this one.
In good faith, I'll give you more for each tag you bring me.
Oh, I put it in inventory... or in storage.
Tell me about the minesuckers.
That's what they call me at the club.
Oh no!
That's what they usually start with.
They start panicking and sweating and they turn really pale and they're just like...
It's the minesucker!
Oh no, run!
And I'm like, hey!
Here for a good time!
Devilish creatures, through and through, they'll stalk you along the waterways and emerge suddenly, screeching their terrible song.
The first time it happened to me, I saw shadows of my squadmates reaching out to me in a feverish dream.
What will we see?
Wait, I kind of want to see something.
When I finally snapped out of it, I was covered in bloody scratches.
They must have sent me running through the foliage.
Since then, I've done my best to avoid the fiends.
Their senses seem to be based on movement, so move carefully.
Are there any shipwrecks around here?
No, anything that meets its end here is quickly swallowed by the silt.
Oh, okay.
That's everything.
Okay, so he marked on the map, right?
Okay, so we gotta go out and around.
Wait, what's... Oh, that's the...
Wait, I do have storage here?
Oh, you're right!
I didn't notice, thank you.
Cargo.
Oh, here's my storage.
And we can put that away.
Thank goodness.
I found a dog tag, here you go.
Thank you.
We'll hang them on the tree.
Here is promised.
Thank you!
We have two.
But I don't think I can... Oh, I can research here.
Is there anything we should start working on?
I could do some of the other engines, so we can get closer to the bigger engines.
Or some of the nets.
Get some good crab pots.
Ability upgrades?
What do you mean ability upgrades?
Yeah, I didn't get the mangrove trawl net or the volcanic trawl net.
I have crab pots!
I have them!
Ability upgrades from the rig.
Oh, that's right!
That's right, that's right.
Okay, you're right.
We'll save.
Undock.
Okay.
Alright, easy.
Easy, soldier.
I'm too fast and it's fast for my own good.
Oh, I need C4!
Okay.
I'm gonna keep calling it that even though I know it's not C4.
Lady.
Seeing the artwork and UI for this game makes me think... makes me want to see...
Wait.
Makes me want to see you experience Disco Elysium.
Oh yeah!
I know that game.
Okay.
Undock.
It was right over here.
So if I just stand still he won't touch me?
What, does he go after me or...
Not quite sure.
Once I'm braver...
Use explosives.
I'm taking a break from rewatching The Sopranos.
Thanks for sticking around.
Where you see one mint, I see four.
You have the wrong prescription, I think.
Tattered Receipt.
We got two messages in a bottle.
For collection.
Engraving is to be as follows.
For Jay.
My shining star.
It feels like years since I have been born.
I do not expect him to write.
I just need to know that he thinks of me from time to time.
The next few lines have been smudged out.
He must return!
More angry smudging follows.
I have written him another letter.
This will be the last one.
Jay Mint!
Jay Phantom!
That's my grandpapa!
It couldn't be.
Jay Mint!
Jay Phantom!
This is tricky, guys.
This is not for the weak.
Don't come in here if you are a little baby.
This is for only hardened veterans such as myself.
What?
Oh, this is for the gun.
And that's some scrap over there.
And we got some fishies.
I thought I heard that thing emerge.
I don't know.
He didn't say where the other guy's dog tags were.
I guess we just kind of have to...
search around for them.
The music is starting up.
That was kind of freaky.
That was pretty freaky, I'm not going to lie.
What?
This area is freaky.
You are actually a wreckage?
Wow, we have an actual wreckage.
More dog tags!
And a gold ring.
I can sell that.
Nice.
This place looks so pretty and ominous.
It does look pretty ominous.
I gotta get out of here though, because I don't...
I do not want to go around through here...
with limited sunlight.
It's already difficult.
He is right behind me.
Where is he?
I don't know actually.
I can...
I got a fish.
We can just go back to this guy's camp.
OK.
We made it.
With limited injuries.
Is this what Florida is like?
I don't think there is enough...
enough gators in this game...
and enough freaky men.
I found some dog tags.
There you go, sir.
Thank you very much.
I found parts of the Mordor.
Freaky gators.
Disagree on the freaky men?
What do you mean?
That's like the whole thing.
Florida man does freaky thing.
That's the joke.
The Florida man?
This is Florida man.
This guy is Florida man but not by choice.
That's the lot.
Now while I work on assembling the Mordor...
you can get started on the next phase of the plan.
Oh, I can?
You may have noticed some contraptions in the lagoons around here.
I've assembled those traps for the minesuckers.
We just need to lure them in there.
Ah, OK.
Once they're in, you can see...
Once they're in, you see, I can fire them with our new mortar.
And that will be the end of them.
No more nightmares.
I'll mark the locations of the traps on your map.
Got it?
How do we get the minesuckers into the traps?
They're attracted to some very specific types of bait.
Your skills will come in handy here yet again.
Is it safe?
Of course not!
Have you got everything?
How do you make the traps?
With patience.
The creatures only seem to sense movement.
So whenever one was close, I froze.
I understand.
What's next?
We need to make three special baits from different combinations of fish.
Alright, the first one.
Ah, is this it?
Yes.
OK, we need...
This guy needs braces.
What about the second one?
I don't have all the fish for the bait yet.
Come back when you've got the rest.
What about the second one?
I have this guy too.
That looks like a catfish.
OK.
What about the third one?
Two fish from the area.
Time to go fishing!
Where do I put the bait?
One of the traps I've constructed in the lagoons.
They're marked on your map.
OK.
So we got our homework.
We have our homework here.
Catfish... I don't think it was a gar.
Because it would have said gar.
Since I've fished that before.
You know?
It would have told me.
Like, hey, this fish is...
This, you know?
What are you?
I don't think we need you, but I'm still curious.
A tarpon?
We got ourselves a tarpon.
Hello!
We got something gross?
This is him!
Oops.
Oh, it is a gar.
You were right.
Sorry.
I doubted you.
I apologize.
OK, so we needed one of him.
I fear I am lost.
What are you?
I caught it.
You knew it was a gar.
OK,
I need to go.
Dang it.
This area is so tricky.
How do I get out of here?
OK, through here.
Through here?
No.
Through...
Oh, the lighthouse.
He is rumbling in my ear.
It's our buddy.
I much prefer him than some of these other guys in these areas, though.
I'm not going in circles.
I got it.
We've got it.
We're fine.
OK, I have money.
We can repair.
Oh, our fishing rod.
Oopsie.
OK, and I'm going to store these, too.
Good thing we didn't lose them.
OK.
Alright.
Good stuff.
What are you?
Do we need him?
I don't think so, but I'll...
What is this thing?
Sergeant fish.
Don't you have a repair part?
It was cheap.
It's fine.
Oh, we got him.
This area is going to be hell to go through in the night time, so I'm kind of nervous.
You know?
Especially if they have the mist chasing after us.
Can I...
I don't want to test if I can run into the...
This guy again.
I guess I could use my...
What are you?
Sergeant fish.
Might be a night fish.
You're so right.
What if it is?
No!
What are you?
Oh gosh.
You sound so close sometimes.
The last ones you need only come out at night.
Well...
It's becoming night.
I can't tell if I can run through these mushrooms or not.
Or if they are going to damage my boat.
It's becoming night.
He's far.
I'm just going to chill in this area.
Mushrooms are bump safe?
They are?
Thank you.
Mushrooms don't damage.
Actually though, we might need to go to old man.
Because we need to make the first bait.
We got the stuff for the first bait.
Why do I feel this sudden chill?
She's here.
She's finally here.
Yeah!
Minto plush!
Thank you for ordering a golden box.
There you go.
I should do it.
I'll just mix these in here.
Load this into a trap then we'll get well clear from it.
When the trap springs, I'll fire upon it with the mortar.
Make sure you bring back proof that the thing is really dead.
You hear?
Okay!
I was going to sleep.
No, no, no, please!
What's in here?
Oh!
It's a thing!
I meet two of you!
Long fin eel!
Nice!
That was easy.
In fact, I'll collect even more of you.
For money.
Oh, I caught 250 fish from rods.
Oops,
I underestimated that.
Okay, my bad.
Sir, I have another bait.
I have another bait.
And I don't remember what the third one is that we need so I actually need to check.
Wait for the last one.
Here you go, sir.
That should do it.
Mix it in here.
Number three.
Okay.
Second one.
Oh, it's a calf fish!
They are the largest freshwater eel species and their blood is poisonous.
At first I was going to say, yummy, and then you said poisonous.
Well, it won't hurt me.
Where can I find the calf fish?
Calf fish is a night time guy?
I feel like a calf fish would be an all day guy.
Calf fish is night only.
Okay.
Maybe we do the first trap.
I kind of want to see it.
I won't be able to see it, you know, since it's so dark out.
Can't see anything.
Oh, there he is.
Luckily this guy glows.
Use my spyglass.
Okay!
Hooray, ten bones!
Thank you, hello!
Thank you.
Thank you for ten bones!
Thank you!
And it could be a special guy too.
Oh, dang it.
Catfish!
Can I get more than one?
Actually they are quite big.
No!
Oh wait, I can't.
I just needed a Tetris.
What was that?
Okay, maybe it was nothing.
I think the vines are moving.
I think so too.
I was like, wait a second, wasn't this...
Where did I come from?
No!
The vines are moving.
Okay, we're fine.
I think.
I'm pretty sure it's over that way.
Oh yeah, look at that.
Are they gonna... wait.
No, I'm going the wrong way.
I don't want to get got by the guy.
I'm all tripped up here.
Oh yeah, you know, the thing that has the sign.
That says this way.
Bait the trap?
I want to do it in the daylight.
Because I want to see it happen.
It's okay, we can get all of them now.
Let's talk about baiting the traps.
Wait for the second one.
Got my special catfish.
Built this into the trap.
Okay, I'm gonna go sell my fish too.
See?
Nice.
Let's go sell.
Let's go bait.
I know where two of them are at least.
If I bait it...
A large cage is suspended over the water.
A small receptacle is floating underneath.
You loaded the bait into the trap.
You should probably move...
This is so unfair.
That's so unfair!
But we didn't lose anything!
Oh my gosh, lucky, lucky, lucky, lucky, lucky, lucky.
That was almost so bad.
Jeez!
Get the proof.
Hold your horses!
Four hundred forty three dollars.
Nice.
And let's repair.
Okay.
Let's get our proof.
It's my first time doing a super chat.
It's my birthday!
Can this skelly get a special MGS happy birthday?
Of course!
Skeletal guzzler.
Happy birthday!
Congratulations!
Happy birthday with salutations!
Happy birthday!
May your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday Skeletal guzzler!
Happy birthday!
Thank you for the first ever super chat!
Thank you!
Okay.
Inside is the obliterated corpse of a minesucker.
Chunk of flesh!
The rest of the carcass sinks out of sight.
Goodbye!
This way.
Next one.
Hopefully he doesn't, you know, appear right in front of me.
Alright, let's try the mushrooms.
They are safe, but I still get...
I still get bumped.
That was close.
Will these guys stop showing up then when I...
when I get them all?
So we will be able to freely roam through here.
That's kind of nice.
Okay.
You load the bait.
You should move away.
Jump!
Now we just need to know where the third one is.
Very good.
Kaboom.
Very nice, very nice.
I chose the hard way.
Why did I do this?
Thread the needle!
The last one, I imagine...
Oh, he marked it.
So if we go through here...
Not gonna lie, I'm gonna miss having this because it's a nice little...
It's a nice...
marker.
You know?
So if I go through here...
Do I need to explode something or no?
Go down here.
Wait.
No, through here.
Sorry, I thought it was blocked off.
What do you do?
Oh, there it is, there it is.
Yeah, a little landmark.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There he goes.
He's kind of cute though.
I like him.
Jump!
Okay, let's get the last one.
And we're good to go.
There we go.
This place is dangerous with fast...
If you have any speed on ya.
Ah.
Drifto.
Initial M.
Fermito.
You should have seen them chasing you.
It's okay.
I'm scared.
Mr. Airman.
I have the creature corpse to show you.
Let's see it then.
We hand the tattered lump of flesh to the Airman.
It's almost unrecognizable, but you both know it couldn't have belonged to anything else.
He pokes at it with his knife, testing the rubbery meat.
He seems satisfied.
This is one of the beasts.
Progress at least.
More to go though.
Oh, you have more?
Yup.
He gives it a few slashes with the knife.
It wobbles a little.
I have more, yes.
You drop the large, bloody carcass in front of the Airman, his eyes filled with sadistic delight.
He bends down and plunges his knife into the soft flesh.
It falls away before the blade, revealing a glint of metal.
Wait, is this our thing?
With a sickening tear, he wrests it from where it was embedded in the flesh of the creature.
He holds it aloft.
You recognize it as a necklace, glistening in gore.
He steps back from the corpse.
A melancholic look comes over his face.
And now, well, that's that, I suppose.
What will you do now?
Can't say for sure.
I thought I'd be asking you for an escort away from this place, but...
This has become somewhat of a home to me.
It doesn't feel right to leave my brothers here.
I think I shall stay a while longer.
In the meantime, I can make up some special bait for you.
It ought to help with your fishing.
This was leftover from the other bait we made.
Now you can make some fresh stuff if you like.
Okay, just any kind of fish?
And you'll make bait?
What if I give you only grey mullet?
The ultimate grey mullet meal, with a little bit of anchovy king.
What if I give you, like, so much of it?
Like, every single thing.
We got so much!
They go crazy for that stuff, day and night.
Doesn't seem to matter.
All sorts of fish usually show up.
Okay, thank you!
We're gonna undock.
And we're going to manifest!
Nice.
Wow, it's so weird seeing the oil rig in the background now.
We've destroyed this place.
We've destroyed the ecosystem.
Is there a chance of seeing Mint Phantom on Inzoy?
I don't know.
I actually don't know anything about the game.
I was watching Kiara with her character creation earlier.
But it only seemed fun because she had the full body tracking and everything.
It's like The Sims.
She didn't even play any of the game.
All she did was...
All she did was the character creation.
Her stream was so funny though.
I was literally laughing out loud.
It was so funny.
Hello mister!
You enter the house carrying the ornate necklace.
The collector recognizes it almost immediately.
An excellent find.
It demands pride of place in my collection.
Relinquish the necklace.
That's the achievement I just got.
He sweeps aside some scraps on a dusty table, candle wax pooling in its corners.
He places the necklace carefully in the clearing.
And I suppose you'll be demanding recompense as well?
I hope so!
He is opening up the book, dust pouring from the pages as he reads aloud.
You begin to feel weak, but you're rooted to the spot.
Knees on the verge of buckling.
Atrophy.
Instantly harvest an entire shoal of fish?
Aren't just the character builder and build...
I think she got early access is what she said.
She LOL'd out loud.
Yeah, I did.
I was LOLing.
I was LMFAOing.
As he finishes speaking, you feel blood rushing back to your legs.
A strange feeling of power grows in your chest.
We're so close.
One more remains.
I loathe to suggest it, but the abyssal plane on the approach to Devil's Spine is a likely candidate.
See what you can find.
I'll mark a location on your map.
Anything else?
What'd you do to me?
Atrophy.
Disphrase in silly calls the closest shoal of fish, readying them for swift reaping.
It can be heard from a great distance, so you not be close to your victims.
But the population is unlikely to recover from such vile trauma.
Use it sparingly.
Call?
Wait, so they just never respond?
Or...
I'm gonna use it right now.
A little fish.
Oh my gosh, we have everything!
Infected.
Wait, what do you mean infected?
Wait.
We've never seen an infected fish before.
That's...interesting.
Oh, why didn't I press the take all button?
Sorry.
Is there a cool down on it?
Must be.
On cool down.
What's the oil fish?
Can I still sell them?
Keep using it.
Did you not see the cool down?
It said on cool down.
It's worth nothing.
No way!
I haven't seen that strange red light in a while.
Wonder what it was.
Hey, are you okay?
The sky like...
Oh, it is actually worthless.
That sucks.
This can also get volcanic, so that's good.
Talk to the dock worker.
Okay.
Don't do that.
I don't like when you do that.
I really don't like when you do that.
That one scares me the most.
Not gonna lie.
I don't know what it is.
Just about the lights.
Oh, I was like, what the heck is that red stuff?
I don't know.
I don't like it.
I just don't like it.
Did you see the MGS Duran Duran edit of you?
Yeah, I did.
Wow!
That's so cool!
Depleted.
Cool fish.
Red light equals spooky.
Red equals scary.
Dock worker.
The dock worker is standing motionless on the edge of the dock, staring down at the water.
He seems paralyzed by fear at what he sees.
What's wrong?
He stares ahead in silence.
You stand with him for a while.
Occasionally, a tremor shakes his body, and his breathing becomes labored.
Are you alright?
He seems unable to respond.
He strains, strains, clenching his fists.
Eyes shut tight with effort.
A tear rolls down his cheek.
What happened?
You notice his neck and overalls are covered in a dark fluid.
The same dark fluid that was leaking from the package you delivered earlier.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
His body relaxes suddenly and his eyes snap open again.
They were cloudy and expressionless.
Fluid rattles through his lungs.
A drop of dark ooze falls from one of his ears and lands on the dock.
It slips between the boards and disappears into the waters below.
What was that?
Eww!
A trembling head turns ever so slightly towards you.
His breathing grows heavy in anger until you step backwards, leaving him standing there on the dock.
He's got ectoplasm problems too.
We're really starting to fill out our book.
We got these big boys though.
Big man... Oh, the mangrove.
Is that a rare fish?
Maybe not.
It's ectoplasm season.
Eww, look at that guy!
That's so gross!
Whoa!
This guy!
We haven't even caught the original.
Whoa!
There's so many more.
At least 150 or more to see.
Should we go to the... Let's go to the oil rig, I think, maybe.
Thank you for telling me to talk to that guy.
That was freaky.
I liked it.
I can grab some wood.
Thank you.
Oh, I gotta sell my fish.
Let's sell my fish.
Hey, hey.
No spooky rocks here, please.
Thank you.
Well, there used to be 150.
Now there's like 200 something.
Oh, fisherman.
What is it?
You look a touch troubled.
Is the fog starting to get to you?
Completely normal around here.
Nothing to worry about.
With a good night's rest, you'll be right as rain by morning.
Oh, he's telling me that I'm freaking out.
Oh, fine.
I'll sleep.
They love me.
They're asking if I'm well.
It's just the ring.
We'll wait until we get a little bit more trinkets and then we'll sell.
I wasn't gonna sleep.
I was just gonna go all the way there, but...
They love me or something.
They care for me.
That was some sick drifting.
Do I do say so myself?
I am feeding them.
True.
Yeah, that is true.
They get food from me.
Do you think there's more than just one cloth here?
Let's hope.
Oh, no!
Please!
I need cloth!
Just one.
Just one cloth.
I was so excited for a second.
Actually...
You know how people do Pokemon Snatcher Pass?
You can do a Dredgfish Feast or Release.
Feast or Release!
I'm gonna go to our little lady friend over here.
And then we'll go to the oil rig.
It's right there.
My reasoning is, I want to use the cloth to do the upgrade before we...
Yeah, I want to do the upgrade, but I didn't want to go all the way back to the initial town.
Feast!
I think I would feast on anything.
I would feast on all of them.
Maybe.
Might defeat the purpose.
I can get this guy!
That's fun.
New fish!
Frill!
It's a frill shark!
These guys are real too.
These guys are real guys.
Nice.
Good find.
Let's try this one too.
It's right here.
An armored sea robin.
This thing is ugly.
Sea robin.
Hello ma'am.
I've come to sell my fish.
Thank you.
And the floating dock.
We were wanting the cargo space.
300 dollars!
We got 4 new cargo spaces baby.
And now we just need 1 cloth.
And then we'll need... We need 5 cloth.
3 scrap, 4 plank, 3 special metal.
What's our storage look like now?
Pretty good.
And we got a lot of research.
We have a lot of research parts.
Wait, what if I... One moment.
What if I do this?
Okay, watch.
Bait.
Use mixed bait to attract 3 different species.
And then, watch this.
Yasified sea robin.
Snake mackerel.
I would like to sell my fish.
78 bucks, that's it.
Stingy.
Sleep.
Did that use up all my bait?
Is it one time use?
Actually I didn't check.
Yes it did.
We'll grab another couple then.
We'll grab a couple.
Bye bye, bye bye, bye bye, bye bye.
We must make haste.
Lest those little guys come and try to eat us.
This looks big.
This looks like money.
Money.
I sound like Mr. Krabs.
I'm becoming a real fisherman, aren't I guys?
Money.
What are you?
A pale skate.
It's so cute.
He's so cute.
None of these look like...
I know that's scrap.
Then what is that?
Is that also scrap?
It looks like it.
Is there no...cloth?
Oh my god!
Cloth!
More cloth!
I don't know why it's so hard finding cloth in this game.
Oh my god.
We just need...
Two more pieces.
We just need two more pieces.
Awesome.
Do we only have the Iron Rig DLC?
No, we have both.
I forgot what this guy wanted me to do.
I know it's marked on the map.
I'll do it eventually, I guess.
There's like a big island.
I can see the island, I just didn't know it was ever there.
Fishing more important.
So true.
So, so true.
What are the DLCs?
There's...
There's one for this oil rig that we're about to head to.
And then there's a...
There is a...
Ice area.
That I kind of explored just a teensy teensy bit before.
At the beginning.
At the beginning of the stream, I mean.
I see glow...
Glowing fish.
Red roses too.
Please don't haunt me.
Fine.
You ass.
It's like right on it.
You stinky...
Oh, that's right.
He wanted me to find some stuff.
What did he want me to find?
Oh, that's alright.
It's all in the...
Crab!
It's all in like the...
Area.
But we can get paid.
Undermarket?
Do you pay me?
No.
Who pays me?
The generator pays me.
Thank you, sir!
Foundry.
Okay, I have to remember what everything does.
Tech lab.
This is $50.
Enhanced lights.
I don't really use my foghorn, but...
Can identify fishing spots at a distance and mark them on... Mark them on your map?
I think the stronger lights probably will be good for me.
I want to know what tier 2 is.
Captain Minto, could I please get a shanty for my birthday?
Uh... uh...
You can.
Just don't expect much.
Uh, yo ho!
I've been sailing the seas for many sea times.
And I've never seen a Dr. Tyrannosaur quite as fine.
And on his lovely sea birthday, we all yip and cheer.
And grab yourself some spirits and beer.
Yo ho, it's your birthday.
Yo ho, we just celebrate.
Now get back to fishing.
Yay!
Was that one better than before?
Was that better than before?
That was amazing.
Bears, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Alrighty.
I need another box.
We'll go find one in the wild.
Wait, how...
What do we need to like, make one?
Oh, that's right.
Cloth and...
I don't think I have... Oh no, I have everything.
What's tier 2 though?
What is tier 2?
The shanties sold me.
You can count on me singing silly songs.
I'm guessing for these, I need the initial part, right?
So we have this one, the winch.
Yes.
Oh, and a dark canister.
And a crate.
Okay.
Interesting.
Oh wait, infused winch.
Wait.
What do I have?
What do you need?
Oh, hydraulic rod.
We got the infused rod.
They gave me that.
So I don't need to purchase it.
Complete missions to get it.
Okay, okay.
Like the science lab one.
Okay, so we're gonna go to the Undermarket.
And we're gonna have him install...
This.
So uninstall...
For now.
And we're gonna install...
This.
And I guess we could install something else too.
We can stack it.
I wanted to see what the install time was.
Okay.
Repair.
What did I miss?
Not much, not much.
I'm just fishing.
We'll go find some more boxes.
Sleep.
And let's go to the goopy areas now.
I could go to the volcanic area, but I kind of want to check out the goop.
What's this?
Oh.
Enhanced light.
Do I have to have it equipped?
I guess not.
Goop.
It's goopin' time.
Yep.
The DLC adds so much.
I'm kind of shocked.
At least for the oil rig.
A wheel!
Bye bye.
I don't have time.
We got fish to fry.
Okay, goop.
The DLC does have some cool stuff.
We got goop, we got goop.
Oh, I see how it works.
We got whatever that thing is.
It's cool.
I like it.
I like this guy.
There we go.
More?
Okay, depleted.
We got some goop.
Discard.
Bye bye.
We don't want him to... I think that might infect it, no?
Is that going to be a big goop bubble?
How do I know?
How do I know what parts I can fish at?
Here?
Oh yeah, okay.
I'm so bad.
Discard.
This just seems to be a normal guy, no?
Over here.
Oceanic!
No!
Goop DLC.
I think this is one of the things the guy wanted, maybe?
I might be crazy.
I guess we'll head back and see.
I don't quite remember.
I don't think he needed a stingray.
If he did, then he's got one.
DLC fish sparkles with an orange glow.
Grab some of these too.
We'll always sell them, you know?
Back to Mother Base.
Hello.
Do I need to equip this?
Oh, no?
Stay back, you misty beast.
Feed the generator.
It hungers.
It hungers for the puffy...
Hungers for the puffy, puffy squid.
What did you want?
I knew it.
I need to buy some crab.
Pots.
Coastal.
Where?
Oh, maybe the other side?
Generator.
Feed.
Undermarket.
Oh, we got more of these.
Oh, sorry.
Wait.
Oh, no!
I can't buy crab pots here.
That's okay.
We gotta head back to the place anyway.
I'm late.
How is the fishing going, boss?
It's great.
We're fishing.
It's already been two and a half hours.
I feel like it just started.
Gosh, I can really get lost in this game.
Your eyes sparkle truly like sapphires tonight.
Thanks!
Really reeled me in and got us all hooked.
Wait a second.
We hit up this goop.
Let's go to this goop.
Bam!
Memory generator does not pay as well as the fishmonger.
So if you need money, don't...
Thank you.
Good to know.
What does the dark goop taste like?
Someone said it tastes like a barbecue.
Wait!
I think that's a box.
My box senses are tingling.
It's a box!
And I think I just saw...
maybe a dog tag.
Two boxes!
Nice.
Just a box.
Is this a dog tag?
What is this?
Why are you glowing?
Oh, it's a flag!
A snake flag.
Serpiente.
Alright, we got our goop.
Wait, this isn't the...
Oh, it is the goop we were going to go to.
Look at that.
We're too good, you guys.
We are too good.
Why is this one glowing?
Are these special fish?
You guys said it had an orange glow.
Oh, I see, I see.
Oh, oceanic.
You also oceanic?
No, we can't...
Oh, but I've gotten this one.
Dang it.
What the hell is this creature?
It's...
Oh, he wants this thing too.
Tolmonstrom.
Sure.
We go to all you can eat?
The music got quite spooky, huh?
Oh, sorry, my bad.
I wanted to do...
This, and pursuits, and specimens.
Paddlefish, sea cucumber.
We gotta go get ourselves a crab pot.
So let's go do that while we're here.
Almost missed my turn.
She said yes.
Did I?
People are saying one of the spots had one more box in it, not depleted.
Wait, they are?
Wait, there was?
Did I miss it?
There was?
Yeah, you left one.
Oopsie.
Hold on, why did I come here?
Oh, for crab.
Well, you sell the crab, sorry.
Crab.
Thank you.
We can go back out, even though it's dark and spooky.
You don't think the boat will see me, will it?
He's coming awfully close.
Turn around.
Thank you.
Not around, not... Turn... Go away!
We are stronger now.
The goop is here.
I'm guessing I have to place the crab in the goop.
Whoa, it's so pink!
Eat.
Crab.
Drop.
And grab our haste again.
And... I don't remember actually where the...
They were like over... somewhere.
I actually can't remember.
No, I've already honked at those guys.
You're sickos.
You just want to see me die.
You're all sickos.
You want to see me panic.
Okay, we got that guy.
And that's oceanic.
So gloopy.
It was...
I can't quite remember where it was at.
Oh, to the left.
Over that way.
Just not into the...
Mist.
My muscle box already arrived today.
Oh, I see it!
Thank you guys.
I hope you're ready for a Disney World trip this weekend!
I want to go to Disney!
Have fun!
Thanks for taking me with you!
No, no, no.
Don't do that.
What if I use this?
A rat tail.
Can I fit these guys?
These are a little bigger than I expected.
One
moment please.
We can get this guy at least.
Tetris time.
Boom, baby!
Yeah, I don't want to hear your funky whispers.
Tetris Pro.
I might be...
I might be a professional.
Wow, guys.
The sunrise on the open sea.
I
want a view with my boat in it.
Holy moly!
Catch it!
Sorry, I thought I had haste.
Time for me to go.
I'm pretty sure that was like a random event kind of similar to the...
The whales and stuff, but I think you're gonna need a bigger boat.
That was so neat!
They come out when you're crazy.
Really?
It's a random event for crazy?
I'm crazy!
Oh yeah, I'm pretty crazy.
How's it going out there?
Here you go, sir.
Look at this thing's mouth.
This thing's mouth is so funny.
We gotta go find a coastal paddle fish.
Just because we're here though and these guys are big, I will sell them.
And we'll put our cargo...
Wait a second.
No.
Not you.
Tech lab.
I guess let's do...
This.
Instruct.
I wanna see what tier 2 is.
Tier 2?
That's done.
Loch Ness Monster probably.
Nessie!
Fun fact, even though it looked like two guys, that was all one creature.
Wait, what?
Sorry, but it is time to see another maid.
What are you talking about?
What?
You're seeing other maids?
I'm so confused what's happening.
What's going on?
Traitor.
Yeah, get his ass.
Get his ass.
The creature you encountered was a singular creature.
Oh, I thought that.
Yeah, I figured it was one big fish.
Leviathan.
Seeing Emma.
No, don't speak her name around me.
Oh, here are the samples.
What was the factory?
Sorry, I'm getting confused what everything is.
Oh, okay, that's right.
I still have one box, so...
I could always get one of these if I wanted to.
We'll become uncrazy probably eventually.
Maybe.
Who knows?
If this is crazy, I don't want to be right.
Wow, big shark.
Come here, come here.
Oh.
Why is it crossed out?
Because it's oceanic, yeah.
What does this do?
Wow!
Oh my god, it like lights... I mean, it said it lights it up, but I can hold it.
It's so cool.
Oh my god!
We're getting some crazy encounters right now.
What if I had just gotten... What if I was just right there?
Okay, we gotta go around this.
Get chomped.
Right here.
Surely our thing is bobbing up and down.
That's not good.
What is that?
Oh my god, what is this?
What do I do?
What was that?
Dang it, oh shit.
We need coastal anyway.
Ooh, fiddler crab.
Please give me what I need, thank you.
That was freaky.
Love how full of evil my shipment of plushies was.
They're really great to eat.
Please treat your meato plushie with care.
Oh, we need some explosives.
Wait, do I have... No, we need some explosives.
Hot dog indeed.
What's this thing?
Shallow.
We need some explosives.
I think that's one of the special parts.
What are you?
Was this something we needed?
Oh yes, the battle fish.
That's it.
I think I can only take one, maybe.
Let's see.
Perhaps I can finagle two.
We can probably get two.
May I have fish?
Thank you.
We probably need to sleep tonight.
What if I don't want to sleep though?
The ocean calls for me.
I had to put my meato in the drawer.
The cat kept running off with her.
I've never had a cat that would take my plushies or anything like that.
That's so cute.
Sell, sell, sell, sell.
Sell, sell.
We'll put this guy in storage for now.
That should be fine.
We have everything, minus the little crab thing.
And the little sea pickle, I think is what it was.
Cat, oh she's meato too.
No one wants to kill me!
Oh, I was going to say it's all cleared up.
Nevermind.
Let's repair some of these too.
I know this one needs repair.
The other one is small, but we can still repair it.
Or I'll just sell it.
This one right here.
Pick up.
We'll sell this one.
Man, I love fish.
I love fish.
Let's sell this.
I'm so glad people are finally getting their plushies though.
Happy, happy, happy, happy.
Wait, can I sell you?
I can't.
Uh oh, nevermind.
I wonder if you can honk to assert dominance now that you have such a massive horn.
Oh, will hear my horn.
And cower in fear.
Uh oh, wait.
He's still fresh.
We're all good.
He's like just right out of the package.
Oh my god.
I'm going to put another one in this.
Well, it's got to be coastal, right?
Or no, it doesn't have to be coastal.
Sorry, I was thinking of the other fish.
We'll go put one over here.
I believe these were the pre-order ones.
I'm going to put it right in the center.
Grab bot.
Did I check this thing over here?
I guess I did.
Was there more cloth?
Hold on, I'll go around.
I don't feel like going through the icky water.
That might be cloth.
No.
It's wood and scrap.
Oh, it was the SOS guy there.
Let's go deliver this guy while he's still fresh at least.
Even though he doesn't necessarily need it to be fresh.
The guy that cursed me.
So relaxing.
Look at the skies.
The sunset on the ocean.
Just the waves.
The sound of waves and my engine.
Nothing else.
And also the eldritch creature that resides below.
Thank you so much for four months.
Thank you!
And the train sound?
What the heck was that?
Ok, we just need this little man.
The sea cucumber.
Sea cucumber, please!
Please, please, please!
Arrive.
Paddle fish.
What is the purpose of this rig anyway?
Ok.
Aren't you going to stop the drill?
Apparently.
The drill team will take their time to try and ensure minimal disturbance.
How does one seek?
Seek?
Cucumber.
I have to do this so that we can potentially unlock these tier twos.
Let's go to sleep though.
Normally I'd be fine with wandering around.
But we're trying to get stuff inside our...
Trying to get stuff inside our traps.
I don't see cucumbers like spray like...
When they're trying to escape, when they get scared, don't they like spray like some sort of white gooey substance and it's like...
It's icky and gross.
Or am I thinking of something else?
They vomit their own intestines.
Wait, hold on.
Sorry, my chat froze up once again.
That's their guts.
Oh, nasty.
That's really their guts?
Wow.
Is it not on a whitish color?
They purge their innards.
What?
Mork, right?
Wait, is this the one that I missed actually?
So I totally found a completely unrelated one before.
That's so funny.
Unless this respawned.
I don't think it... Wait, there's more!
I can't tell.
They do respawn.
That would be so funny.
I
know you might be excited about potential collaborations and of course...
I would love to collaborate with many, many people but please try to remember the rules about not bringing up other Vtubers.
Why is it all these common crabs?
Why?
Why all just common crab?
I'm getting so unlucky.
Unless I'm just not putting it in the correct place.
Now we have some more cloth, baby.
Let's go.
Depleted.
No!
Discard.
Wait, this one's not even...
We got the sea kookaburra!
Sorry, I don't know why I keep pressing escape.
I got a trophy for it.
Actually, I will do this one.
Why not?
We can get some money.
There it is.
Let's go!
No!
It doesn't help.
Okay, good to know.
Dang it, I thought the light would be like...
And like, get rid of it, you know?
Light attracts cursed mist.
No!
Please!
I'm crazy!
Oh my god.
Okay!
The scientist looks taken back.
He consults some papers on his desk, then leaves through an old encyclopedia.
This is remarkable.
Some of these species... Have you caught these before?
They haven't been seen outside the fossil record since, well, ever.
I suppose it could make sense.
The fish are opening, cause some kind of disturbance in the deep, possibly spooking some of these fish up the water column.
I'll run some tests on these.
The scientist is interrupted by the foreman outside, shouting through his megaphone again.
The foreman below bellows in order.
Engage reverse gear!
Get that drill outta there!
This doesn't seem very good, I think.
No?
This seems bad?
I think this is bad.
Oh no!
Not inside!
Ah, hell.
That's enough.
Drill is clear.
I repeat, drill is clear.
Shut it down.
As I was saying, I'll run some quick tests on these specimens.
Though, from the sounds of things, you may have some additional samples to gather.
It seems the reservoir is more unstable than we anticipated.
Even with the drill removed, it appears the fissure is continuing to expand.
Unfortunately, there have been reports of some contaminants leaking from the fissure in isolated pockets.
There was always a chance this might happen.
The engineer at the factory has been working on a system to siphon such contaminants from the water.
I'd very much like a canister of it.
Oh, ok.
I've been trying to keep a record of where all that dark liquid has been showing up.
Come see me if you need pointing to any contamination patches.
Alright.
Yeah, they're totally isolated.
It's fine.
Tier 2.
Material gathering.
Let's get to work.
The factory's core facilities have been improved.
Siphon trawler.
For dredge?
Once deployed, this trap expands into a larger formation.
Filtered fluid in canisters.
I see.
Someone collects dredge!
That's huge!
You want the siphon trawler?
Yeah, we can passively gather materials.
Let's...
What do I need?
The basic trawl net.
Obviously I don't have that.
Oh my gosh, our thing is full.
Not full, but, you know, lots of good stuff in there.
Which I will sell to the generator.
Eat up!
I wonder what tier 2 is, though.
Do the starting extension on the building soon.
Oh, good!
Ok, construct.
We can get more upgrades.
The tech lab is fully built now.
Let's see what's this.
Turning speed!
Reverse gear!
Chain optimizer.
Increases the winching speed of your dredge crane.
What does that mean?
I mean though, please don't fish and eat me.
I don't eat.
I sell.
You dredge faster.
We don't have any boxes though, so...
Boost the reverse speed of your vessel.
Wait, so increases the pulling power of your fishing reels.
Fishing speed, heat absorption.
Troll catch rate.
I like that too.
Wait, I like all of these.
I'm guessing these are like passive.
Um...
Passive, like uh...
Enhancements?
Yeah?
So I don't have to like attach them in here?
Is what I'm trying to say.
Oh, you put them on the boat and it gives you a bonus.
It's stackable.
Oh, ok.
They take up inventory.
Oh, ok, ok, ok, ok.
So that's what I was wondering.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ok, um...
That's what I meant.
Sorry, that's what I meant by passive.
Sorry, that's probably the wrong word.
Yeah, ice, but...
Ok, I like turning speed a whole lot.
These are good upgrades.
What do you want now?
Oh, the samples.
So let's go.
Let's get this.
I need the basic trawl net.
So I'm gonna...
Undermark it.
Grab that.
Basic trawl net.
Factory.
Oh, I don't have a box!
No!
I need a box!
Ok.
You know what?
Screw it.
I'm just gonna buy one.
Haha.
It's ok.
We'll get more, guys.
We'll get more cloth.
It regenerates every couple days.
Oh, I had one.
I'm such an idiot.
No!
You know what?
That's ok.
You guys, that's ok.
That's ok, because we can get this, too.
We'll get this.
Can I keep it in my storage and it works?
Or do I have to have it on my cargo?
In the boat.
So...
Not storage.
Is what you're saying.
Equip the siphon trawler.
You have to equip it.
Wait, where did it just go?
Oh.
So like, down here it will work.
Yes.
Ok.
Good, good, good.
Oh wait!
My fish!
I sold all of them, right?
I can't remember.
I think I did.
To the generator?
I'm pretty sure I did.
Ok.
Alright, let's sleep.
And let's go get some goo!
It's gooping time!
Let's goop it up!
Yeah!
I'm ready to goop!
Yes!
Good morning, goop!
Goop morning!
Goop morning, Minto.
Oh gosh, almost 9AM.
That's the perfect time to goop.
I love me a 9AM gooping.
Here we go.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Wait!
Oh I get to eat it up!
I missed a spot.
No goop in there yet though.
Will I still be able to get the goopy fish though?
The cleansing.
Like the fish that are in the goop?
Does it matter?
Yeah?
Ok.
Oh my gosh, we're keeping the oceans clean everybody!
Good thing I got that easier...
easier turn.
I'm cleaning the ocean.
Goop soup.
So I guess once it's filled, we'll have a...
a goop...
amount.
Of course I'm gonna get all of it though.
I feel I can probably turn off my light here.
While we're working on this.
Even though I can't see very well.
I think the mist will annoy me otherwise.
I'm working.
I'm actually doing a job right now.
I'm actually doing my maidly duties of cleaning.
I'm actually cleaning at the moment.
Straight up gooping it on stream, freaky style.
Thank you so much for the tag gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Ok.
Did I get all that goop?
Seems like it.
Hey!
Stop it!
I turned you off.
What are those?
What is that thing over there?
What is that thing with the eyes?
Wait.
What the hell is that?
There's several of them.
What is that?
That's new.
Hi!
What are you?
Ah!
Oh.
Oh my god.
It disappeared.
It doesn't care about me I guess.
Just a little guy.
He's just a little gooper.
He's like, I also enjoy a good goop.
Where is all the goop there?
Oh.
Yeah.
I can't get this thing yet.
Did I miss a spot?
24 hour gooping.
It's a, it's a, it's a, you know.
It's, it's a tough job but someone's gotta do it.
Someone's gotta goop in the middle of the night.
I'm a goop sweeper.
Yeah, put me on that show, Dirty Jobs or whatever.
So that's...
What's that sound?
Oh, it's just a little guy.
It's just a little...
Yeah, we're fine.
Look, it's almost daytime.
Starting to lighten up a little.
We've been gooping all night.
Wait, do these things show up on the goop?
Your gooping days are over!
I literally gooped all night, you guys.
Oh!
Oh, it's an evil one!
It's coming directly for me!
It wants me!
Why are you so obsessed with me, please?
Let me do my job!
Oh my gosh, I missed a single spot.
This thing stays out even in the...
Oh!
Oh my gosh, did you guys see that?
That was pretty awesome.
That was pretty good.
That's not good.
Oh, that's not good.
Anyway...
Lighten up all the goop still.
All the goop.
I like this part.
Oh, my...
What you got in there?
Thank you.
Oh, my hole is pretty damaged.
What's wrong with my vision?
What's wrong?
Something slithers into your cargo hold.
No!
We got an infected guy!
I'm gonna get rid of him.
My what was damaged?
My hole?
What did you think I said?
We're almost done.
We've almost cleared the goop, guys.
We've almost cleared the goop.
Oh, what just happened?
Oh, it's probably broken.
Missing item.
My gooping days are over.
We were so close.
And that, I feel like, was a smaller area.
This area over there seems huge.
It's gonna take forever to get all that goop.
I gooped too high.
The birds, are they good birds?
Oh, they're bad birds.
No!
They're taking my crabs!
I worked hard for that.
No!
My engine!
Stop, please!
No!
I want them to get them away.
OK.
I stayed crazy the whole day.
It's because I can't stop thinking about goop.
I'm like...
Return canister.
Have you collected the containment I have?
He holds it up to the light.
For a moment, the fluorescent bulbs in the room flicker and buzz, light recoiling in a pattern against the ceiling.
Thank you.
It's always important to know what we're dealing with in operations such as these.
You'll go blind if you goop too much, you know.
It's just a little radioactive.
If you saw anything noteworthy about the liquid, he doesn't let on.
Don't forget about that other thing I asked you to do.
Have you had time to... Wait, when did you ask me to get these?
What?
Excuse me, sir.
When did you say that?
What?
When did he say this?
Do you know anything about these mutated fish I've been finding?
Mutations are present in almost all species, and fish are certainly no exception.
In my years of study, I've seen fish with extra fins, eyes, and even heads.
Yes, they're a relatively normal part of the development of a species.
Occasionally, they can be influenced by external factors, and only in exceptional circumstances.
What's going to happen to the fisher that opened up?
Now that the drill has withdrawn, it should settle down.
Provided nothing else disturbs the seabed.
Yeah, this is gaslighting.
I think we're being gaslit.
I think we're part of some secret... I don't know.
I feel like the gulp... The gulp?
Sorry.
I combined the gulp and the government.
I was gonna...
The colt?
I almost did it again.
The colt and the government are fighting against each other for these freaky fish.
Oh my gosh.
This is how my brain works, you guys.
I literally combined colt, so I said gult.
Because I said government and colt.
Anyway, now that the drill has withdrawn...
Oh, maybe not the government.
I guess this company, huh?
I expect that given enough time, it will be filled with sediment entirely.
In the meantime, it appears to have opened up some interesting opportunities for research.
You silly goop.
Please repair my $160 for repairs.
Wait, they took my sea crab and everything.
Oh man, we got no money.
Gooping with the gult.
Back to gooping.
Oh wait.
Do they still need the goop?
They're working for big BP colt oil government goop.
What does that mean?
I know that there's some like here, right?
That like requires...
Yeah, some of these require it.
I wonder if having the dredge material, like the harvester would be good because...
Because then we could start collecting stuff for the big...
Well, we gotta go to... What do you want?
What do you want?
You want a land set fish?
Trilobite, Nautilus, and Solacena.
Oceanic.
Oh, I do need an oceanic one though.
Okay, we gotta update our...
We do have to get a different rod at least.
Coastal shallow.
Infused hoist.
Actually, let's get the infused winch.
But I need a hydraulic rod.
Bunch of creepy crawlies, pretty much.
But I need the hydraulic.
Gosh, it's so expensive.
I should have never sold them earlier.
I guess.
And we need to go get a box.
Let's go find a box.
Maybe one has respawned by now.
Yeah, we're gonna get the bigger boat pretty soon-ish, I hope.
That's also kind of a goal.
Get some more, you know, some more...
Some more cloth.
Cloth.
Box hole!
Nice.
There might be some...
Cloth respawn.
Not yet, sad.
Sad, sad, sad.
I wanna see how close we are to getting the upgrade, though.
Wait, I thought the stuff spread all through here.
No?
Did it not?
I thought it did.
The dredge net, see how it works.
True.
Yeah, I could get it now.
Here, that's what I was looking for.
Oh, just one cloth is what we need.
Okay, cool.
We can upgrade this to them.
And then we need three cloth.
Okay, more rod.
Alright, let's start filling this up and see, kind of get a gauge of what all we need to start collecting.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
I know where to get another one of these.
I just have to buy some...
Oh, I have more cloth.
Oh, there we go.
Oh no, I just didn't put it in.
So we need two wood, one scrap, two cloth.
Oh, it's only two cloth.
I thought it was three.
Okay, I thought it was five in total.
And then I know where to get another refined metal.
We gotta go blow up something.
So let me buy that.
Wait.
Don't you do not sell...
She doesn't sell explosives?
Okay.
I don't have any in inventory.
Storage, no.
Okay.
Yeah, we gotta go to the merchant, I think.
How do I wanna do this?
Since we... Okay, let's first get the dredge thing.
And this guy does... I think this guy sells some too.
So let's first go get that.
And... Wow, Detective Shane!
Welcome to membership, thank you so much.
We'll go get that.
We'll put on the dredge.
Net.
We'll be good to go.
Oh.
Speed.
More speed.
Oh, my lights are off.
Since when?
I was gonna say, it's kinda hard to see.
What happens if the bar reaches the top?
You take some damage.
Cute.
Thank you very much.
How much are you selling this for?
425.
Okay, okay, okay.
Probably since the gooping season.
I've been gooping.
Oh, should we get another engine?
I just realized I have an extra spot.
We can go faster.
Yeah!
Wait, these are all facing... Oh, my God.
This looks horrible.
You guys are all facing different directions.
Oh, this looks like the worst.
Who installed this?
Alright, and I think we need... Oh, hold on.
I think we also need the basic trawl net.
Let's go to the factory.
And then...
Material harvester.
Storage.
You.
And...
Thank you.
And we're gonna have... We're gonna install...
Okay.
We're gonna be so much faster now.
We're gonna be crazy fast.
Crazy speeds.
Like no one has...
What the... Oh.
No one has ever anticipated...
Someone going at this speed before.
It's absolute insanity.
Look at...
My gosh, it's so clean.
Thermometer!
That's so cute.
I want to squish.
Don't squish my eye!
Clean.
Clean, clean, clean.
Gathering discarded materials.
I guess we can get this once we switch back to...
Our usual.
This big boy.
Our heavy duty trawl net.
We can get the flotsam trap and just kind of like...
Leave it out and collect stuff passively.
Yeah!
Still missing that map piece.
I know!
Actually, there was a place that I wanted to explore that I know we haven't been to yet.
Wait a second.
Boxhole!
Whoa!
There we go.
More box.
It's been a bit... Hello.
Hello!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
Alright.
Oh, there's more.
OK, we'll drop these off at storage.
Skate geek.
That's what the plushie is for.
To squeeze, to squish.
For everybody who's gotten the plushie, is her head really dense?
Is it like super, you know...
Yes, it's so dense.
OK.
I told them to make it less dense, but I guess it never...
I guess it never happened.
That's OK.
I just... The Mito plushie holds lots of secrets.
Lots of knowledge.
It's so big and dense, it's perfect.
Like, you don't need to include the big part.
Well, it's big because it has lots of knowledge, you know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Orcas!
Orcas.
Killer whale.
Will there be a third wave of pre-orders?
Yes?
Eventually I would like to.
I wasn't sure when to do it, because...
I didn't want like, you know...
Like a...
How do I say?
Well...
There was a reason and I don't remember what my reasoning was.
Wait, I don't even remember why.
I don't remember.
I had a reason.
I promise.
But there should be, eventually.
Wait, can I blow this one up or do I have to go around?
OK, I have to go around.
Right here.
Hey!
Whoa!
This one's intense.
Nice!
And that's some refined metal, baby!
Alright, so now we just need one more.
We just need one more.
OK, hold on.
Let's get our lights back on.
And... haste.
We must make haste.
What?
What if I honk back?
It lights them up!
That's so cool!
It like lights up what areas I can...
Wow!
Interesting.
OK, I'm done.
Echo location.
What did we get in our thing?
I wonder.
We got some... a boot?
What the hell?
Fancy boot!
Large and sturdy looking boot.
Waterlogged leather straps are laced through shiny metal clasps.
OK.
What?
Honk if you love me though!
Honk honk!
There's a snake in my boot.
I guess can I sell this?
Yeah, it's just a little trinket.
OK, cool.
What was I working on?
Sorry guys, I completely forgot.
Oh, I wanted to get the...
Oh my gosh, the upgrade is so expensive.
It's half our money basically.
And then from there, we get all the upgrades and we don't even have to get a new hole?
Like, we're crazy.
I do know...
Let's just sleep.
Honk honk.
Let's go to sleep and we're gonna go to...
The oil rig.
We're completely aban...
We've completely abandoned the main plot for a bit.
That's OK.
I'm gonna gather some supplies right here because I know there are some.
Right here.
And I believe that's cloth.
Nice.
Oh wait, I don't think I need anymore wood.
That's alright, I'll still grab some.
We'll need it in the future.
Honestly, once I do this upgrade...
Or once I...
Once I finish upgrading the ship to the full capacity...
We don't really need so much supplies anymore, do we?
I forgot that dredge can also be...
Like little trinkets.
That'll scrap.
We'll do another one.
I don't remember if it was one or two that we needed more.
We can do another one.
I'm dumping out the...
That's good for now.
Mmm...
We... I think we still need one cloth for the upgrade.
Or two.
One or two.
Let's go sell the boot.
Two cloth.
Don't need anymore wood.
Cloth is by the place where you got the refinement.
There is?
I will check.
Oh, I didn't bring the... Oh, I did bring the boot.
Nice.
51 dollar boot?
That's like a pair of boots.
There is?
Over here.
Trust me, I got that right there.
That cloth.
Oh, it is.
You're right.
Thank you very much.
It looked like scrap to me earlier, which is why I ignored it.
Good eyes, everybody.
Good eyes.
Oh my gosh.
Are we gonna get the upgrade?
No, I still need... I could buy it.
I could buy the refined metal.
Should I just buy it?
It's 400 dollars.
Once we start getting big fish again...
Right now we haven't made so much money because we haven't been like oceanic fishing.
I've been doing quests instead.
Buy it?
OK!
Let's buy it!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you guys.
No, but you don't sell it!
I have to go to a merchant.
Dang it.
We have to go to the merchant.
Screw it.
It's only midnight.
We are brave.
We've been on these oceans before.
The water is really dark.
We are... Yeah, we are.
Leave me alone.
Thank you.
I'll be right in.
Just a second.
I'm concentrated.
I'm locked in.
I'm there.
I hate that guy!
Driver says thank you!
I've been trying to keep a record of where all that dark liquid has been showing up.
Come see me if you need any points for decontamination.
OK!
Thank you!
I haven't done anything with him yet.
What sucks is I'm gonna buy this and then we're gonna have to go all the way back again.
That's okay though.
Because this place doesn't have a dry dock.
That's okay, that's okay, that's okay.
I still need this thing.
Which we can make actually.
Yes.
Coastal and shallow.
I'm gonna sell this guy.
I can't sell this guy.
Why can't I sell you?
I can only discard it.
That sucks.
Maybe because they gave it to me.
Because we're gonna make this guy.
No!
You guys, I took off my old net.
I took off my old net without getting the goop out first.
I wish it would...
I wish it would auto empty.
That's so frustrating!
Oh my goop!
I spent endless nights trying to get the goop.
What do we wanna do?
Time for another goop sesh, I guess so.
I guess so.
I already uninstalled it.
But I will...
Do this guy too.
I guess it doesn't really matter.
He's there!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my go...
I took it out for nothing.
That's okay though.
Alright, so we have this.
I'm gonna put that in storage.
Let's go back, upgrade my ship.
And then we can also go to the gale area to get these.
And we can start fishing oceanic fish again.
Oh, but actually then I guess I don't need the goop trawler.
So let's uninstall again.
And throw you in the storage.
Yeah,
we'll do this one again.
We'll do this one again.
We just took a whole day to do it, but that's okay.
That's okay.
Alright.
Nice.
You can get a swordfish with the upgraded oceanic rod too.
Which is what I have now, right?
This one.
Yes.
Yeah, we can go get that guy.
Alright.
Okay, that all worked out.
Was that my first hit?
Didn't it say that upgraded hull can take a hit?
What we're gonna do is we're gonna go get some...
There were some special fishy over here.
Some special goop fish over here.
And there's boxes.
But I wanna have room for the fish.
So I'm gonna avoid those boxes for a second.
We're gonna ignore them.
Oh my gosh, there's another box.
There's so many boxes.
Why would you ever make boxes?
I guess if you're in a hurry and you have a lot of supplies.
Oh!
There we go.
I forgot.
My bad.
We're in business now.
Alright, what are you?
No, no.
I can get one!
Oh my gosh, this shape is atrocious.
Can I get two?
I can get two!
Let's go!
Those are gonna sell for big money.
We're pointed toward... What is that over there?
Many dollars.
Since we're here, let's just go in.
And sell.
And make money.
The boat upgrade.
What are you?
Are you a small fish?
I can catch you.
You can do one more.
Nice.
Don't get lost!
Hell yeah!
And we got these crab pods.
We gotta do something with them.
Let's go.
We'll also go sell our stuff.
Dry dock.
Here we go!
Is there anything here now that we can upgrade immediately?
This is... Let's do the extra storage space first, obviously.
Definitely not this, but...
We're clearing out space in the storage, which is good.
No way, we have enough cloth before everything else?
Times have changed.
What is it looking...
You got so much space!
Let's go sell some stuff.
So roomy.
Got... Oh, also...
Deliver flag.
Do you want to attach it?
No, I love my pirate flag.
Paint the boat.
The roof.
I can't do sharp mint yet.
What do you need again?
A kingler crab.
Oh, a mutated kingler crab.
Cerebral crab.
Kingler.
And we sell.
Oh, my bad.
Sell for 92 bucks.
Oh, sell a total of 1,500 dollars worth of trinkets.
Let's go.
To the gals!
We're off to the gals.
Off to the gals.
Off to the gals, gals, gals, gals.
Off to the gals, gals, gals, gals, gals.
What are you?
Wait, I can't get you, can I?
Oh, I see now.
All the stuff that's gross in here.
Like you.
We got ourselves a nautilus.
The music is really spooky.
The ambiance.
We got you.
What about you?
What are you?
What the hell was that?
Lancet fish!
What's happening?
Oh, we got splashed upon.
Stop screaming whatever you want.
Oh, it's these little creature things.
Ew, I don't like them.
Ew, shut up.
I don't like them, I don't like them.
Oh, that area over there is where I want to go.
I want to go there.
If I honk, will they disappear?
Oh, we need to deliver this guy, huh?
Yes.
Nice, now we just need three pieces of wood and we're good.
Honk?
Let's see what happens if I honk.
They're gone anyway.
Yeah, you stinking creatures.
This area we haven't been to, you guys.
Look, it's all covered in goop.
I never got to... I don't think I got to explore it before it got gooped up.
So sad.
We never got to check it out before it got all gooped.
Abyssal thing.
We shall have to return.
What's in here?
A rotting chest peeks out from the skeleton of a wrecked ship.
Some wood, I'll take it.
Ok, I'm off to bed.
So long, Minto.
Thanks for all the fish.
Thank you.
Thank you, JJ.
Good night.
It wasn't even sparkling, you son of a gun.
I wonder, are these things like...
Are these things ships that I just didn't get to quick enough?
And they got inhabited when I was playing the game?
I got crabbed.
I got crabbed real good.
This is just a tiny island with nothing on it.
If I go back to it, will it be upset again?
Excuse me.
See you later.
What are you?
I'll hold off for now.
I don't think the scientist cares, but I don't want them to rot until they are gone.
You know what I mean?
He's just an angry little guy.
He's just an angry guy.
I think... I see it now.
I think I was gonna say... I think the oil rig is all the way behind that mountain.
Oh!
Yeah, my net is deployed.
Yes, my net is deployed.
No worries, no worries.
Where am I?
Oh.
Ok.
There's a lot of goop to scoop up, you guys.
There's a lot of goop to scoop.
It's like in a crazy amount.
Oh, dang it.
I was trying to avoid it.
I like how the music is kind of like Minecraft, where it's just a little random.
It's been four hours already?
No way.
I actually am starting to get a bit sleepy.
I'm enjoying the DLC stuff, though.
The collecting of the different kinds of stuff is really fun.
I like it.
I like this game.
It is very easy to get lost in the sauce, isn't it?
Here's my samples.
This one is a special guy.
Ok, you better take care of this lancet fish.
He's a special one.
Wait a second.
Yeah, they are...
Oh, he's the crab type and he's the shallow type.
Ok.
Look at him.
He's our special little guy.
He looks mutated, doesn't he?
He looks gross.
That should be...
enough wood, I think.
Let's go to sleep.
I'm almost going to call it.
Almost.
We're going to sleep.
We're going to go get our upgrade.
And then I think I'll call it.
Because we're really close.
I think you needed three.
Yeah, I have one here.
And I'm going to pick up two more.
Are you saying you've been duped by the goop?
Duped by the goop.
I never thought...
any goop would...
I can't...I just...
It's just...unfathomable.
No?
I just...
Ok,
I'm done crying.
Let's fish a little.
We can sell these fellows.
I should also deploy my crab pots.
But I believe I probably have to deploy it around...
Around the gale place.
Mother Basin Antarctica, they made these DLCs just for you.
Right!
Thanks for the comfy fishing tonight.
Thank you!
I know, right?
It feels like this game was kind of made for me.
I'm not going to lie.
I'm a big fan.
Hey!
We need to sell things.
We need to make money.
We need to make money pronto.
Let's put that in here.
Oh, there's the compute.
I was looking for you.
My organization is not nearly as clean as before, but...
It could be worse.
Whatever.
Ito, I love you so much.
Thanks for being the best ghost mid.
It was my birthday yesterday and I have a song.
Of course, Kurokami-sensei!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Kurokami-sensei!
Happy birthday!
Thank you for the super chat!
Sorry I'm a bit late.
Always a treat to watch you enjoy slash get addicted to a new game, Minky.
Like I said, I think it's just really nice for me to have a game that I feel...
I can really just kind of brain off.
Even though I'm brain off, but there's also...
There is a good amount of thinking in this game.
Don't get me wrong, I am having to be like...
Where should we go?
What should we do?
How should we do it?
But yeah...
Brain off for sure.
More management in minigames.
I really like that.
Yeah, I like it a lot.
Let's go put some crab bait.
The goopy gooper goop song.
I'm a goopy gooper, yeah.
You're a goopy!
Oh, I think my...
Yeah, our trawl net is broke.
That's okay though.
Actually, I really don't feel like we need it so much anymore.
No!
Come back!
This way.
Smash boom!
Thank you for the five gifted!
I like your profile picture.
Crab pot at the cliffs for the paint.
Oh yeah!
Your streams are always something I love to model and draw to while watching.
Thank you, Minto.
Thank you!
Am I your muse?
Thinking about Minto while you're drawing?
Alright.
If any little creepy crawlies come out, I'm gonna zap them.
Watch this.
Where are you, creepy crawlies?
Oh, I hear one.
Sorry.
I think I need to move.
It's like...
It's like a scared tooth.
Let's uninstall you.
Reinstall you here.
How did you get over there anyway?
Uninstall you.
Put you in the storage.
Grab the storage.
Pick you up out of storage.
Put you in here.
Big Minto love.
Thank you!
I'm gonna save on money a little bit right now.
But we're gonna start getting some big fish again so that I can, you know...
Yeah.
So that we can make some more money back.
We're gonna repair.
We gotta start making some money again, guys.
We're gonna sleep.
We're gonna undock.
We're gonna go around.
Can I get you?
Yeah.
Let's go to the shallow water.
I know there was some over here.
We dropped below 2000.
It's Minto over.
We'll make it back!
We'll make back the money tenfold.
Oh, we will once I drop the net.
We'll make it back 500 fold.
A bajillion fold.
700 million fold.
This is it!
This is the other creepy crawly we need.
That thing is sick.
Sickening.
Abyssal.
Too bad it's abyssal.
Are you abyssal?
Oh, no.
We can take another one though.
One billion dollars.
Exactly.
What are you?
A wreck?
Oh, this is the wreck fish.
I'll take you.
No!
Why do I get punished?
Shattered wreck fish.
That's cool.
I like that.
Do these make a lot of money?
We got two!
Let's go.
Bony wreck fish.
Nice!
We got two mutants.
Call me...
Dr. Xavier.
I'm collecting mutants.
I'm gonna wreck fish.
And our crab things.
Might be full.
Sorry, I know I said I was going to stop.
I will, in a minute.
I will... Holy moly!
Holy moly!
Oh, tiny little anchovies worth nothing pennies.
Undock.
Check our crab net.
He's so cool!
I like that guy.
That was worth.
What is the last thing that he wanted?
I don't remember.
It was...
Was it the Trilobite?
I think if I sleep, my fish will go stale.
As long as they're not rotten though, I feel like I can give it to him.
Probably.
Maybe.
Ouch.
Yes.
He's still fresh.
Stale is a pass, but rotten isn't.
Right, right.
Because I want to sleep.
Nah, we'll just go back.
We'll let a couple days pass.
And also collect some fish.
We have a method.
There is a method to my madness.
There is a method.
Where am I?
I guess I'm going the long way.
Let's go through a little morrow.
Or...yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go around this island.
That's what I'm trying to say.
Yeah, yeah.
Here.
Through.
There is a method to my madness.
I can't.
We're zooming.
We're zipping by.
Stealth Gamer.
Oh my god, you guys.
Okay, this might sound crazy.
Have you guys seen the Totally Spies game?
The newest one.
Came out like last year, I think.
I kind of want to play it.
No.
Can I show you?
The Totally Spies game.
I've been trying to keep up.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
I know, I know.
Leave me alone.
Okay, hold on.
I'm going to show you a screenshot, you guys.
I'm going to Steam.
It's on Steam.
Oh, sorry.
That's Enzoid.
Uh...
I was looking it up earlier because I was curious.
Totally Spies Cyber Mission.
Hold on.
Okay, I'm going to show you guys.
We're going to watch the trailer, alright?
Real quick.
Oh, you can still hear the game.
Shut up, game.
Game, be quiet.
Be quiet, game.
Okay.
One moment, please.
This is just a brief intermission.
This is a brief intermission, okay?
I need you guys to watch this trailer with me.
Of the Totally Spies game.
And tell me you see what I see.
Ad break.
This is not an ad.
Okay, here we go.
Why are they whistling?
I hate that.
Look how cute they are.
Wait, is this the...
I hope Clover is fetishized in the game.
Okay...
I feel like I need to play this game.
We'll make it out.
Oh my gosh.
I actually didn't watch this with audio earlier.
Also...
The reviews are mixed.
There's Jerry.
Everybody wondering where Jerry is.
The reviews are mixed, but I feel like...
I feel like I have to play this game.
I feel...
You guys...
You guys!
Look at this.
You get to use gadgets.
And you get to...
Wait, where did it go?
Here we go.
Go undercover.
Look at this.
You hide in the locker, which is nothing special obviously.
And also, I don't know if you guys know this, but...
Original, I don't know if it's in the new Totally Spies if the new voices are this.
But Sam in Original Totally Spies is Jennifer Hale.
Whoa, really?
Yeah.
It all comes back to MGS.
It does.
It all comes back to Metal Gear Solid.
Also, this game was released...
This game was released...
On Halloween of last year.
Why did they release the Totally Spies game on Halloween?
Anyway...
I'm glad that we can have that little break.
Fetish gear.
Wait, what do you mean?
No!
What were we doing?
Oh, I dropped off the specimen.
And we're waiting to get to that.
And I'm going to...
Sleep.
We're going to undock.
Now, I'm just a little crazy, but not as crazy.
Rice Knot, what did you say?
What did you say?
No joke, a Walmart employee just walked up to me and cold opened with, So, when do you think they're making a Metal Gear movie with Keanu Reeves as Snake?
Why did somebody come up to you and say that?
Why did they say that to you?
Look, they are sneaking in a box.
I need to play this.
You don't understand!
How many games do you get to play as walking in boxes and it not be Metal Gear related?
It's all Metal Gear!
Literally hundreds.
No, shut up!
No!
Zelda Wind Waker.
Yeah, it all leads back to Metal Gear.
They did it first.
Let me play Totally Spies.
It's like all I watched when I was sick in Japan in January.
I just had Totally Spies on, okay?
I was like, gosh, this show really was freaky.
Raise your hand if you discovered you had a fetish from Totally Spies.
Oh, no.
I thought you were the...
Never watched it?
Oh my gosh.
It's like...
It's the...
Fetish show.
It really is.
Never seen it.
I like him.
I'm a fan.
Oh, it's depleted.
Dang it.
Let's go sell him off, baby.
Can I use this thing again?
Are you still hungry?
Nope.
All done.
That's a cool ass fish.
I love... Isn't it great how emphasis can change a whole sentence?
English is so funny.
Here's your gear, girls.
What's this, Jerry?
Alex, that's just a cardboard box.
Perfect, I'll take this one.
Are you winning, Minto?
I think so, actually.
I think we're doing a pretty darn good job.
I didn't develop a fetish from the show, but I had a massive crush on Sam.
Understandable.
This guy alone is $426.
Our net profit, true.
That is insane money.
That's crazy money.
Look at him.
He's so cool.
Oh my gosh, I'm in love with this fish.
I love him.
I'm gonna sleep again.
I'm gonna give ourselves as much time as we can with these crab nets.
Ivory Impaler is a great name.
Right.
So awesome.
You guys, I've dredged.
I dredged a lot this past week.
But after today's stream...
I don't think there will be much dredging until...
For a little while.
I have no time next week.
What do you love more, the fish or us?
So yeah, I'm sorry to say we'll have to wait for the finale of dredge.
I'll probably do another long, long stream.
But that gives some people time to catch up, no?
Dang it.
Gives people some time to catch up.
If they couldn't watch the 10 hour...
It wasn't 10, it was like 8 hours of dredge.
Don't ask questions you don't want answers to.
Alright, let's check on our crabs.
Grabby crab crab.
Let's go.
What's that?
Rock crab.
Okay,
it put all of them in my thing.
Very nice, very nice, very nice.
I think the blue crab is by...
Is by the basin.
That's where we got all the blue crabs before.
Keep that big crab for the altar.
Altar?
What altar?
Actually, I'm gonna undock and we're gonna go back to...
The...
The oil rig.
She's thinking of me, she loves me.
Delulu.
Everyone point and laugh.
Delulu, Delulu.
Delulu, Delulu, Delulu.
Thank you for 6 months of membership.
Thank you.
You have to manage your fuel in this.
No!
Luckily you don't have to manage fuel.
But there are other managing things.
You think I'll go super crazy this night?
Nah.
Let's just book it.
We should be fine.
Just book it, book it, book it, book it.
Who are you guys pointing at?
Yourself?
Are you the delusional one?
I may be a little delusional.
You guys would think so if I told you my real thoughts about Metal Gear.
Maybe.
But don't worry about it.
For now.
Wait, I need to flush the can.
Someone ordered it!
Thank you!
Uh-oh.
We're going crazy.
No, you can't be camping by the dock.
That's so unfair.
Anyway.
Don't worry about our mental state.
She's delusional and denying how cute she is.
You tell lies!
I say I'm very spooky and scary and creepy and crawly and you say I'm cute and that's none of those things.
You tell lies, you tell lies.
The scientist inserts a syringe into each of the creatures, now laying long dead on the slab.
From each, in turn, he draws a vial of fluid.
This will only take a moment.
Some vials contain the type of blood you might expect, deep and red, catching glints of light from the fluorescent bulbs overhead.
Other corpses yield a dark, clotted substance that seems to crawl up into the vial by itself.
It shimmers with a quiet iridescence, as if it lit from inside.
He places the vials of what should be fish blood in a rack in front of him.
Down in the deep, something begins to brush against the leg of the rig.
What?
Wait, what do you mean by that?
I think we released...
Oh my god, that's so much goop to clean up.
Please god no, that's so much goop.
There's something gigantic, something incredibly powerful gripping the rig.
So it's really here.
The scientist steps away from the nearby window, knuckles still white from gripping the frame moments before.
If you're so spooky, then why don't you come haunt me?
I will!
I already have.
Fisherman, the structure, the people on it can't stand up to this.
I have, well, I had a student.
She was developing some technology.
C for creepy, U for unnerving.
I thought you were spelling something else.
Scalion, oh my gosh.
T for terrifying, E for evil.
Minto is cute.
I can't spell.
How about now?
You tried.
He turns back and presses his forehead against the glass.
It was a way of communicating, I suppose.
We were working on emulating a language that we didn't fully understand.
She began to twist the words.
But she didn't agree with Iron Haven's methods.
So leveraging my role on board for the research society, I pulled some strings and had her posted far away.
To Stellar Basin.
That's his student!
Please go and find her.
I hope she's progressed her research sufficiently to help us.
And while you're there, try to catch some of the local specimens.
He's so needy.
I think they hold the key to understanding what we're here for.
I'm gonna sell some of this stuff.
Now
I am finished for today.
Yes, yes.
Thank you guys.
For more dredge.
This has been fun.
I like this game.
I could've probably gone another five hours.
But I should also rest.
Very nice streaming, though.
Thank you guys!
I hope you guys had fun.
I had fun.
I hope you guys don't mind me playing a lot of dredge recently.
Are you alive today?
I can't see your ghost horn.
My lady.
A tip of my hat to you.
Of course I'm not alive.
That would be silliness.
That would be ultimate silliness.
Thank you for the superchat!
We shall all tremble in fear tonight under your terrifying seat.
Hope you have a great day off tomorrow.
Thank you!
Nice try.
Thank you guys!
Have a good night, have a good day.
I'll see you guys when I see you next.
Thanks for fishing with me.
I like fish and I like fish.
Yeah, well played.
Yeah, thanks for all the fish.
This is so fun.
Thank you guys!
I won't see you tomorrow, unfortunately.
But I'll see you when I see you next.
Unless you're watching the bot.
You might see me tomorrow.
Bye bye!
Otsumito!
Thanks for watching!
Thanks for hanging out!
Bye bye!